THE NIGHT BEGINS ON. THE SIXTH
WELL IT'S TIME TO BEGIN. GOOD
MORNING EVERYONE WELCOME TO
BUDGET SUB COMMITTEE NUMBER
THREE- WE ARE MEETING IN ROME
FORTY TWO OH TWO FOR THOSE OF
YOU WHO ARE LOOKING AT THE
SURROUNDINGS OF THE GAME THAT
DOESN'T SEEM RIGHT I FEEL LIKE
WE'VE YOU KNOW WE'VE ARRIVED
THEY SENT US TO THE BACKGROUND.
APPARENTLY THERE WERE TECHNICAL
DIFFICULTIES IN THE IN THE
OTHER ROOM BUT YOU KNOW IF
YOU'RE A CONSPIRACY THEORIST
MAYBE THERE'S SOMETHING GOING
ON I DON'T KNOW WHAT IT WOULD
BE BUT MAYBE THERE'S SOMETHING
GOING ON. SO BEFORE WE BEGIN AS
HAS BECOME OUR HABIT- IN THE
COVE IT ERA I'VE BEEN ASKED TO
READ SOME DIRECTIONS REGARDING
PUBLIC PARTICIPATION. IN
TODAY'S HEARING TO HELP INSURE
THE SAFETY OF EVERYONE HERE
WHILE ALLOWING FULL PUBLIC
ACCESS TO THE DISCUSSION. TODAY
WE'RE HAVING A PHYSICALLY
DISTANT AND PERSON HEARING IN
THE STATE CAPITOL IN ROOM FORTY
TWO- TO. MOVE FROM ROOM FOR
THIRTY SEVEN FOR THOSE OF YOU
WHO ARE KEEPING SCORE. IN ORDER
TO KEEP SIX FEET OF SPACING WE
CAN ONLY ACCOMMODATE A FEW
MEMBERS A MINIMAL CONDITION OF
STAFF AND A- LIMITED NUMBER OF
THE PUBLIC AND MEDIA. HELLO I
CAN TELL YOU THERE'S ONLY ONE
PERSON- SITTING IN THE- IN THE
AUDIENCE AT AT THE MOMENT.
THEY'RE ALSO STRICT PHYSICAL
DISTANCING PROTOCOLS FOR THE
PUBLIC TO ENTER AND LEAVE THE
CAPITAL AND FOR THOSE HERE
TODAY TO MAKE PUBLIC COMMENT AT
THE APPROPRIATE TIME. AND I'LL
RESTATE THIS WHEN THE PUBLIC
COMMENT BEGINS BUT IF ANY
MEMBER OF THE PUBLIC IN THE
ROOM WISHES TO SPEAK. I'LL ASK
YOU TO RAISE YOUR HAND AND
THAT'LL ASK- YOU WANTED A TIME
TO APPROACH THE MICROPHONE.
PLEASE RESPECT PHYSICAL
DISTANCING AND DO NOT TOUCH THE
MICROPHONE. YOU WLL HAVE ABOUT
A ONE MINUTE FOR PUBLIC COMMENT
I DO TIME IT- AND TO TRY TO
KEEP EVERYBODY ON TRACK BUT-
YOU KNOW- THERE'S A- ONLY A-
LIMITED AMOUNT OF TIME-
PARTICULARLY WHEN WE HAVE MANY
PEOPLE WHO ARE- ASKING TO
PARTICIPATE IN PUBLIC COMMENT.
YOU CAN EXIT THE HEARING ROOM
ONCE YOUR PUBLIC COMMENT IS
DONE IF YOU'VE GIVEN IT HERE
AND THE HEARING ROOM. OR RETURN
TO YOUR SEAT BUT PLEASE OBSERVE
PHYSICAL DISTANCING UPON
LEAVING THE CAPITAL- LEAVING
THE ROOM LEAVING THE CAPITAL
INCLUDING LIMITED ELEVATOR USE-
WE ONLY ALLOW ONE PERSON AT A
TIME. IN THE ELEVATOR THE
PANELISTS ON THE AGENDA AND THE
ALEJO ARE- AND THE- DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE ARE APPEARING
REMOTELY USING ONLINE
TECHNOLOGY LET ME POINT OUT AS
HAS BEEN THE CASE FOR THE PAST
COUPLE OF MEETINGS WE ARE NOT
VOTING IN THE COMMITTEE TODAY
THERE ARE NO VOTES. BEING TAKEN
AND THAT WILL EXPLAIN- CLEARARC.
SOMEWHAT OF AN ANOMALY THAT
OUR- WHAT IS NORMALLY CALLED
THE VOTE ONLY CALENDAR IS
CALLED A NON PRESENTATION
CALENDAR TODAY THESE ARE ITEMS
THAT WILL. BE ON THE VOTE ONLY
CALENDAR IN THE FUTURE WHEN WE
DO BEGIN TO VOTE ON- ITEMS. BUT
SINCE WE ARE NOT TAKING ANY
VOTES TODAY. THE NAME OF THE
HEADING IS NON PRESENTATION
CALENDAR THERE WILL BE NO
PRESENTATION ON THOSE ITEMS
LISTED. OF FOR NON PRESENTATION.
WE ARE ACCEPTING PUBLIC COMMENT
AT THE END OF THE HEARING AS I
MENTIONED OKAY. IN THE HEARING
ROOM BUT ALSO ON THE PHONE THE
PHONE NUMBER TO CONNECT IS ON
THE COMMITTEE WEBSITE AND
SHOULD ALSO BE ON THE SCREEN IF
YOU'RE WATCHING OVER THE
INTERNET. THE PHONE NUMBER IS A
TOLL FREE NUMBER. EIGHT SEVEN
SEVEN SIX NINE TWO EIGHT NINE
FIVE SEVEN. AGAIN THAT'S NUMBER
EIGHT THAT NUMBER IS.
877-692-8957 AND THERE'S A
PUBLIC ACCESS CODE TO PUNCH AND.
ONE THREE ONE FIVE FOUR THREE
SEVEN ONE THREE ONE. FIVE FOUR
THREE SEVEN IF YOU ENCOUNTER
ANY PROBLEMS PLEASE CONTACT THE
ASSEMBLY BUDGET COMMITTEE AT.
916-319-2099 AGAIN THAT NUMBER
IS NINE ONE SIX. THREE ONE NINE
TWO ZERO NINE NINE AND A STAFF
MEMBER WILL ASSIST YOU AND-
HOPEFULLY RESOLVE AN ISSUE THAT
YOU MIGHT HAVE. CONNECTING I
WILL REPEAT THAT- ALL OF THOSE
NUMBERS AGAIN AS WE BEGIN OUR
PUBLIC COMMENT AGAIN PUBLIC
COMMENT WILL BE AT THE END OF
THE HEARING. AFTER WE HAVE.
GONE THROUGH THE ENTIRE AGENDA.
SO IF- THERE'S NO FURTHER.
COMMENT AT THIS TIME WE WILL
MOVE ON TO THE DEPARTMENT-
UNDER OUR ITEMS TO BE HEARD-
ISSUES NUMBER ONE THROUGH FOUR.
THE DEPARTMENT OF PARKS AND
RECREATION. YES GOOD MORNING MY
NAME IS WILL SHOPS ONE AND THE
DEPUTY DIRECTOR FOR
ADMINISTRATIVE SERVICES AT
STATE PARKS GREAT SEEKS TO
PROVIDE THANK YOU THIS ITEM SIX
PROVIDE SHORT TERM
SUSTAINABILITY TO THE HARBORS
AND WATERCRAFT. THIS FUND
PROVIDES RESOURCES FOR BOATING
RELATED PROGRAMS AT THE
DIVISION OF BOATING AND
WATERWAYS STATE PARK UNITS. AND
SEVERAL OTHER DEPARTMENTS FOR
AQUATIC INVASIVE SPECIES
CONTROL. THE PROPOSAL BEFORE
YOUR REFLECTS A BALANCED
APPROACH THAT REDUCES
APPROPRIATIONS SUSPENSE CERTAIN
TRANSFERS AND INCREASES THE
VESSEL REGISTRATION. TWENTY TO
SEVENTY DOLLARS ON A BIANNUAL
BASIS OR TEN TO THIRTY FIVE ON
AN ANNUAL BASIS. THIS PROPOSAL
ALSO REFLECTS INPUT RECEIVED
FROM BOATING AND WATERWAYS
COMMISSION AND STAKEHOLDERS
THAT OCCURRED DURING COMMISSION
MEETINGS AND WORKSHOPS OR THE-
PREVIOUS YEAR. THIS IS A FIRM
APPROACH INTENDED TO PROVIDE
SHORT TERM SOLVENCY TO THE FARM
WELL LONGER TERM SUSTAINABLE
MEASURES ARE EXPLORED.
SPECIFICALLY THE DEPARTMENT
WILL CONSIDER MOVING TO MAKE
YOUR VESSEL REGISTRATION. THAT
WOULD BE BASED ON BUSTLING.
THIS WILL PROMOTE MORE AFFABLE
APPROACHED A FEW RAISING.
DISCUSSIONS ALSO INCLUDE THE
POSSIBILITY OF SOME OF THE
COLLECTION RESPONSIBILITIES
YOUNG BEING W. TRIGGERS COST.
AND HAVE FLEXIBILITY
STRUCTURING EXPLORING NON
MOTORIZED VESSELS IS EXPANDING
THE QUALITY OF OUR PROGRAM MORE
BROADLY COVER COSTS ASSOCIATE
WITH THE A. I. S. PROGRAM. SO
HOW DO GET HERE. OVER THE PAST
TEN YEARS INSPECTORS HAVE RISEN
YOU PROGRAM SOMETHING FUNDED
FROM SOME REVENUES HAVE
DECLINED. SPECIFICALLY IN OUR
QUALITY THIS IS SPECIES PROGRAM
WHICH TREATS WATER HYACINTH
DONS A EXPENDITURES HAVE GROWN
FROM SIX AND A HALF MILLION
DOLLARS IN. TWO THOUSAND EIGHT
FOUR POINT SIX MILLION IN TWO
THOUSAND TWENTY ONE. IN TWO
THOUSAND FOUR TRANSFERS TO THE
PUMP BEACH RESTORATION FUND TO
SUPPORT GRANTS FOR BEACH
NOURISHMENT ISSUE ALSO WERE
INITIATED. INTRODUCTION OF
THESE FOR RECURRING OBLIGATIONS
HAS CREATED SIGNIFICANT
PRESSURES ON THE SPOT. IN
200013% OF THE BIGGEST ALL ACT
THE BUDGET ACT INITIATED A TEN
MILLION DOLLAR ANNUAL TRANSFER
TO THE STATE WATER PROJECT. TO
REPAIR FACILITY DEBT AND FUND
PROGRAMS RELATED TO
RECREATIONAL ACTIVITIES ITS
STATE WATER PROJECT WRESTLERS.
ADDITIONALLY THE DIVISION OF
BLOOD IN THE WATER IS LIKE ALL
STATE DEPARTMENTS HAS
EXPERIENCED RISING WAY
COMPENSATION COSTS FOR WAGES.
RETIREMENT CONTRIBUTIONS
HEALTHCARE COSTS. YES US
QUESTIONS HAVE NOT HAD A
CORRESPONDING INCREASE IN
REVENUE RESOURCES ADDITIONAL
WHAT. FONT FINALLY IN TWO
THOUSAND NINETEEN CLARIFICATION
TO THE WAY THAT THE STATE
COMPTROLLER'S OFFICE TRANSFERS
FUEL TAXES. REDUCE THE AMOUNT
RECEIVED BY THE HEART OF WATER
PROPER BONE FUND BY FIFTEEN
MILLION DOLLARS ON AN ANNUAL
BASIS. THIS PROPOSAL THE FUND
IS FACING A FIFTY TWO MILLION
DOLLAR ANNUAL DEFICIT I WILL
NOT HAVE SUFFICIENT RESOURCES
TO CONTINUE SERVICES AT CURRENT
LEVELS. THIS PROPOSAL SEEKS A
BALANCED APPROACH TO SOLVING
THAT DEFICIT BY RAISING TWENTY
TWO MILLION DOLLARS IN FEES THE
SENATE APPROPRIATIONS WALLACE
FORTY NINE. SEEKING TWENTY
MILLION DOLLARS GENERAL FUND
OVER TWO YEAR PERIOD. AND
SUSPENDING TRANSFERS TOTHE
PUBLIC BEACH RESTORATION. WE
BELIEVE THIS IS A PRACTICAL
MEASURE TO TAKE IN THE SHORT
TERM THAT PRIORITIZES KEEPING
ALSO REGISTRATION FEES WHILE.
MAINTAINING SERVICE LEVELS AND
LIMITING THE AMOUNT OF GENERAL
FUND REQUEST. WE ARE PROPOSING
APPROPRIATION REDUCTIONS IN OUR
FORTY MILLION DOLLARS IN.
PRIORITIZE OPERATIONS THE
HIGHEST NEED RECOGNIZE THE
STORE CLOSED ITS MANAGER
CAPTURE SCENES IN ORDER. THIS
INCLUDES DECREASE TWO POINT
FOUR MILLION DOLLARS IN THE
CURRENT YEAR AND ONE POINT NINE
MILLION DOLLARS FOR THE BUDGET
YEAR TO STAY OPERATIONS FOCUSED
PRIMARILY PRIMARILY ON THE
QUALICUM SPECIES. THIS PROGRAM
WILL HOLD CERTAIN POSITIONS
BAKER I'M PRIORITIZE ST MERRY'S
AND MAY REDUCE OVERALL ACREAGE
AND TREATMENTS TO ACHIEVE THIS
GOAL. HOWEVER WE DON'T EXPECT
TRAIL CHANGES TO THE SERVICE OF
THE RIVER BY THE DIVISION AND
MAILING ON GREATER
REIMBURSEMENTS FROM. THE FORMER
WATER RESOURCES TO OFFSET THIS
REDUCTION. THIS PROPOSAL ALSO
INCLUDES A DECREASE OF ELEVEN
POINT NINE MILLION WHO WILL
ASSISTANCE PROGRAMS WHICH
CONSIST OF THE FOLLOWING. FIVE
POINT FIVE MILLION DOLLAR
REDUCTION TO THE PUBLIC AND
PRIVATE MARINE A LOAN PROGRAM.
THIS PROGRAM HAS BEEN UNDER
PRESCRIBE FOR SEVERAL YEARS AND
IT IS UNCLEAR HOW MUCH DEMAND
EXISTS FOR THIS PROGRAM. GIVEN
THE POTENTIAL THESE
INFRASTRUCTURE LOANS GENERATE
RUNNING FROM OURS WATER
PREFERABLE THAN WE ARE
PROPOSING PARSONS PROGRAM.
UNTIL WE CAN ASSESS WHETHER
DEMAND CAN SUPPORT FUTURE CRIME
RATES. ARE THIS IS ASSESSMENT
WILL INCLUDE ANALYSIS OF
INTEREST RATES. WE ARE ALSO
PROPOSING A FIVE POINT SEVEN
MILLION DOLLAR REDUCTION BOAT
LAUNCH FACILITY GRANTS. THESE
GRANTS ARE MADE TO QUALIFYING
PUBLIC AGENCIES TO FOCUSSOLELY
SUCH AS RAMPS OR INCLUDES
ASSOCIATED PARKING AREAS
RESTROOMS LIGHTING. THIS
REDUCTION REPRESENTS THE TRUE
AVERAGE SPEND OF THESE PROGRAMS
ARE PAST FIVE YEARS IT SHOULD
NOT HAVE A MATERIAL IMPACT ON
BY A PARENTS ARE PROVIDED.
FINALLY WE ARE PROPOSING A
SEVEN HUNDRED FIFTY THOUSAND
DOLLAR REDUCTION OGDENSBURG
MUSSEL INFESTATION GRANTS
PROGRAM. IS BROWN SUPPORT
PREVENTIVE MEASURES TO HELP
PROTECT CALIFORNIA'S WORSE FOR
MUSLIMS STATION. AGAIN THIS
PRODUCTION REPRESENTS THE TRUE
AVERAGE SPEND OF THESE PROGRAMS
OF THE PAST FIVE YEARS AND
SHOULD NOT HAVE A MATERIAL
IMPACT ON LOCAL SERVICE
PROVIDER. THIS PROPOSAL DOES
NOT REDUCE THE AMOUNT AVAILABLE
FOR GRANTS TO LOCAL LAW
ENFORCEMENT PERSONNEL SEARCH
AND RESCUE OPERATIONS ANOTHER
MARINE PATROL OPERATIONS.
HOWEVER THIS PROPOSAL DOES
CONSIDER TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE
TO CAP THE FINANCIAL AID
PROGRAM AT ITS CURRENT LEVEL SO
THAT THE FEE INCREASES NOT
CORRODED BY NEW OBLIGATIONS TO
FUND THIS PROGRAM. CURRENTLY
EXCEEDS THE STATUTORY MINIMUM
BY ABOUT SIX AND A HALF MILLION
DOLLARS PER YEAR. WE ARE
PROPOSING SUSPENDED FOR TWO
TRANSFERS FROM H. W. R. L.
DAVIS DOLLAR TRANSFER AND THE
POPE EACH RESTORATION TRANSFER.
IT IS DAHLE TRANSFERS WILL BE
SUPPLANTED BY GENERAL FUND FOR
TWO YEARS FOR A TOTAL OF TWENTY
MILLION DOLLARS FOR TEN MILLION
DOLLARS PER YEAR. THIS WILL
ALLOW US TO KEEP THE BUS OF THE
REGISTRATION INCREASES LOS
POSSIBLE A LONGER TERM SOLUTION
IS EXPLORE. WE ALSO PROPOSES
MANY PUBLIC BEACH RESTORATION
BACKGROUNDS RISEN TO ALTERNATE
SOURCES WOULD BE IDENTIFIED.
WELL WE BELIEVE THIS EXPENSE IS
PROGRAM FOR THE H. W. R. L. IN
OUR VIEW IT DOES NOT CONFER
IT'S PAST DIRECT BENEFIT ON
VOTERS TO SOME OF THE OTHER
PROGRAMS THAT WE HAVE. BOTH
RETENTION. FINALLY WE ARE
PROPOSING A TWENTY FIVE DOLLAR
PER YEAR OR FIFTY DOLLAR BI
ANNUAL RENEWAL AND EXPRESS OUR
INSPIRATION. IF YOU'LL CHANGE
FROM TEN DOLLARS TO THIRTY FIVE
DOLLARS. FOR ANNUAL
REGISTRATION PAID IN AN EVEN
YEAR OR TWENTY THE SEVENTY
DOLLAR FINANCIAL ALL YOUR-
REGISTRATION. THE LAST INCREASE
FOR THIS THE WAS DONE TWO
THOUSAND FIVE. WHEN IT WAS
RAISED FROM TEN DOLLARS TO
TWENTY DOLLARS BY. WE HAVE
INCLUDED THREE POINT TWO FIVE
MILLION DOLLARS FOR DMV SYSTEM
CHANGES TO FACILITATE THE
SPEAKERS THE PROPOSAL. THE FUEL
JERRY TWENTY TWO MILLION
DOLLARS FOR THE HARVEST WATER
BRADFORD BONTA ON IS. WHAT WE
REALIZE THIS IS A LARGE
INCREASE ON PERCENTAGE BASIS I
WOULD NOTE THAT CALIFORNIA'S
RUSSELL REGISTRATION FEE IS
CURRENTLY THE LOWEST IN THE
NATION. AND WOULD REMAIN ONE OF
THE LOW SPECIAL REGISTRATION
FEES IN THE NATION AT THIS
PROPOSALS FOR. WITH THAT I WILL
UP HER. ANY QUESTIONS MAY.
WRESTLES. THANK YOU FOR THE
APRESENTOU ASIAN AND- I HAVE
ONE UP A QUICK QUESTION WHAT IS
THE RANGE OF FEES AND- OTHER
STATES AROUND THE COUNTRY. WELL
I DO HAVE THAT INFORMATION I
DON'T HAVE THAT MEMORIZED OFF
THE TOP OF MY HEAD BUT IT YOU
KNOW I THINK. ON THE ON THE
LOWEST CALIFORNIA WE'RE YOU
KNOW TEN DOLLARS IN IN. OR
TWENTY DOLLARS BIANNUALLY I
THINK THEY RANGE ALL THE WAY UP
TO A HUNDRED DOLLARS PER YEAR
UP ON THE HIGH END A LOT OF
OTHER STATES DO X. YOUR VESSEL
REGISTRATION YOU NEED TO
ACHIEVE THEIR- THE REVENUE
CORPORATE. WE DO HAVE THAT
INFORMATION I'M I'M BEING I'D
BE HAPPY TO PROVIDE. YOU GREAT
THANK YOU- UNLESS THIRDS OF
WHAT WAS YOUR QUESTION
QUESTIONS HERE. THE BIGGEST ONE
IS IT'S SUCH A BIG INCREASE
THAT YOU'RE ASKING FOR WHY
HAVEN'T YOU ASKED FOR AN
INCREASE OVER THE LAST FIFTEEN
YEARS AND NOW ALL OF US WERE
ASKING FOR I THINK IT'S LIKE
2100% INCREASE. IT'S A FAIR
POINT I THINK IT'S IMPORTANT TO
NOTE THAT- THIS IS REALLY THE
RESULT OF A COUPLE THINGS THAT
HAVE- RUN EXPONENTIALLY OVER
THE PAST FOUR YEARS ONE AIS
EMPLOYEE COMPENSATION.
INCREASES HAVE REALLY-
EXACERBATED THE FUNDING BOUNCER
LAST FEW YEARS. I'M IN TWO
THOUSAND NINETEEN WE HAD A
PRETTY SIGNIFICANT THAT YOU ARE
GAS TAX REVENUE. SO LONG-
CERTAINLY AT THE MORE. TRUE
MEASURE WOULD BE TO INCREASE
THAT HE SLOWLY OVER TIME I
THINK- WE'VE HAD A COUPLE
SIGNIFICANT FIND. CHANGES OVER
THE LAST FEW YEARS I HAVE
REALLY EXACERBATED THE
SHORTFALL AND SHORTEN THE TIME
LINE WHICH IS INCREASING. AND
THEN- DOES THE DEPARTMENT HAVE
ANY DATA THAT SHOWS THAT THE
FUEL TAX DOLLARS IN A
REGISTRATION FEES HAVE BEEN
PLACED IN THE OF H. W. R. F.
ACCOUNT. AND I'D LIKE TO SEE
THAT DATA. CERTAINLY WE CAN WE
CAN PROVIDE ALL THE FUEL TAX
REVENUE DATA ON. THE DEPARTMENT
DOES NOT ACTUALLY DO TRANSFERS
THOSE ARE A PERSON TO STAY COOL
COMPTROLLER'S OFFICE AND WE
WORK WITH FINANCE VERY CLOSELY
TO ENSURE THAT THOSE TRANSFERS
ARE MADE APPROPRIATELY IN
CONSISTENT WITH. STATUTORY
REQUIREMENTS- YEAH ALL BUDGET
ACT REQUIREMENTS. ONE LAST
QUESTION IF YOU HAVE A DETAILED
LIST OF ALL OF THE PROJECTS
THAT HAVE BEEN FUNDED WITH THE
FUNDS. AND I'D LIKE TO HAVE A
COPY OF THOSE. SURE WE PROVIDE
A HARBORS WATERCRAFT BONDS ON
REPORT THAT DETAILS ALL
EXPENDITURES THAT ARE MADE FROM
OUR STATE PARK AND RECREATION
FUND THOSE TRANSFERS- WE ALSO
HAVE A REPORT THAT WE CAN
PROVIDE FOR. OUR PROJECTS
FUNDED BY REASON WATER PERFECT
BALLING THANK YOU'LL TAX
REVENUES- AND THEN WE ALSO HAVE
SB ONE FUEL TAX REVENUES
DEPOSITED IN THE SPRING I
BELIEVE THERE WAS A BUDGET ACT
REQUIREMENTS- COUPLE YEARS AGO
THAT SPECIFIED THAT WE WERE TO
REPORT ON PROJECTS DONE-
PURSUANT TO SB ONE. TO A
COUNTRY SO WE. WE CAN. WHY YOU.
MISTER BENNETT THANK YOU- AT
THE LIGHTS DOWN THE NAM ON.
OKAY GREAT THANK BOB. WHAT WE
TRIED TO RESEARCH THIS AT AND I
COULDN'T GET A CLEAR ANSWER ON
IT. BUT A LONG SAME LINES AS-
BUT MY COLLEAGUE- IT SEEMS LIKE
YOU'VE GOT A LONG PERIOD OF
TIME WITHOUT A FEE INCREASE-
AND YOU MENTIONED YOURSELF THAT
WOULD PROBABLY BE BETTER TO
HAVE STEADY. FEE INCREASES- I'M
TRYING TO FIND OUT. IS IT
POSSIBLE FOR THAT TO BE A
POLICY- WITH THESE TYPES OF
FEES IF YOU'RE TRYING TO MATCH-
ONGOING EXPENSES THAT ARE
INCREASING YOU'RE TRYING TO
MATCH- SALARIES BENEFITS
XCERRA. YOU KNOW THOSE ARE
GOING TO BE INCREASING TO GO
FIFTEEN YEARS EVEN THOUGH YOU
MIGHT SAY HEY WE HAD THIS
HEALTHY RESERVE OR WHATEVER.
YOU KNOW YOU'RE GONNA FALL OFF
A CLIFF AT SOME POINT TIME FAR
BETTER A LONG TERM POLICY TO DO
THAT. IS IT POSSIBLE DO YOU
HAVE THE ABILITY TO SORT TO.
REQUEST NEVER LEGISLATURE
APPROVED- EFIA INCREASED IT HAS
A BUILT IN INFLATION FACTOR IN
IT OF SOME SORT. SURE AND I AND
I THINK YOU ACTUALLY SEE THAT
IN SOME OF THE OTHER FUEL
EXCISE TAX- STATUTORY
REQUIREMENTS A LOT OF THOSE ARE
TIED TO CPI SO THOSE ACTUALLY
PLAYED OVER THE COURSE OF TIME.
I DON'T THINK CITY I WOULD
HAVE- KEPT UP WITH THE RATE OF
OUR PROGRAM EXPENDITURE
INCREASES OVER THE COURSE OF
TIME I DID THAT ANALYSIS IT
LOOKS LIKE WE WOULD HAVE
INCREASED THE FEE ON AN ANNUAL
BASIS FROM ABOUT TEN TO.
FIFTEEN DOLLARS WHICH WOULD
HAVE CRIED QUITE MAD WHERE WERE
UP TO DATE WITH THIS YOU LEVEL
INCREASE BUT CERTAINLY SEE GUYS
IS SOMETHING YOU CAN LOOK TO I
TIRE SPECTRUM CREASES TO I
THINK THE L. L. IS ALSO
SUGGESTED A TRIGGER MECHANISM
THAT WOULD- AUTOMATE A FEE
INCREASE. DEPENDING ON SEVERAL
FACTORS- WE ACTUALLY REPORT
PROPOSED A SHORT TERM SOLUTION
HERE BECAUSE WE WANT TO GO BACK
AND WORK WITH THE BOATING
COMMUNITY STAKEHOLDERS THAT THE
DPW COMMISSION AND TRY TO FIND
A FEW STRUCTURE THAT WORKS- FOR
THOSE FOLKS- AND EXPORTS. OF
THE OTHER OPTION WE'VE TALKED.
YOUR VESSEL REGISTRY FEES
NORMALLY. THE BROADER A AYE S.
B. AB THEBODY MAY HAS AS
PROPOSED. EXPLAINED BENEFICIARY
PAID SMALL FOR QUITE RACES
SPECIES WHICH IS ONE OF THE
LARGEST CONTRIBUTORS TO.
EXPECTORANT RACES ON THIS FUN-
AND I THINK THE OTHER FACTOR
THAT WOULD BE SOMEONE RUNNING
FOR US TO- THE TITLE
REGISTRATION FEES NOW. WITHOUT
A LONGER TERM SIX DISCUSSION IS
WHETHER WE CAN DO THIS THE
INCREASES WITH THE N. B. UNDER
THE CURRENT SYSTEM HOW HOSTAGE
THE SPEAKERS. SO HIS ARE ALL
THINGS BETTER- FOR DISCUSSION I
THINK AS AS WE MOVE FORWARD.
THIS IS THIS PROPOSAL BUZZES
ABOUT THREE YEARS TO FUND
SUSTAINABILITY. DOES YOUR
DEPARTMENT SUPPORT GOING TO
THAT KIND OF FEE. STRUCTURE IN
GENERAL. I DO IT. STRUCTURE OR
AND FOR. ADJUSTED FLEECED.
STRUCK MAY NOT BE A PLACE
ADJUSTED EVERY YEAR YOU KNOW
YOU DON'T WANT TO HAVE A- YOU
KNOW A- DOLLAR FORTY TO
INCREASE BUT YOU. YOU YOU KNOW
MAYBE EVERY COUPLE OF YEARS YOU
ADJUSTED AND ROUNDED OFF TO THE
NEAREST FIVE DOLLARS OR OR
WHATEVER. D. GET GET YOUR- SAID
THINK CPI MAKES A LOT OF SENSE
TO OFFSET EMPLOYEE COMPENSATION
AND THE COST OF GETTING
CREASES- I WOULD JUST NOTE THAT.
RIGHT NOW WE WANT TO MAKE SURE
WORKING WITH THE BOATING
COMMUNITY ON A LONGER TERM
INCREASE SO I THINK- THOSE
DISCUSSIONS WILL REALLY INFORM
WORKMAN'S STANCE ON THE CPI.
THANK YOU. ARE THERE ANY OTHER
QUESTIONS. WE HAVE A REPORT
FROM THE L. A. O. AND TO THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE. YES GOOD
MORNING THIS IS RACHEL EHLERS
FROM THE LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S
OFFICE- AND WE THINK THERE ARE
A LOT OF POSITIVE FEATURES
ABOUT THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL
THAT ADDRESSES THE PROBLEM
IMMEDIATELY BEFORE YOU WITH A
STRUCTURAL IMBALANCE. IT'S
BALANCED IN THAT IT LOOKS AT
BOTH EXPENDITURE REDUCTIONS AND
REVENUE INCREASES WE THINK THAT
LOOKING AT INCREASING FEES IS
REASONABLE GIVEN THEY HAVEN'T
BEEN INCREASED AND SO LONG. AND
WE THINK THAT THE EXPENDITURE
REDUCTIONS OF THE
ADMINISTRATION'S PROPOSED ARE
WELL TARGETED TO TRY AND
MINIMISE PROGRAMMATIC IMPACTS.
THE PROBLEM OF COURSE IS THAT
IT'S ONLY A TEMPORARY SOLUTION
IT'LL BE RIGHT BACK BEFORE YOU
IN A FEW YEARS AND WE THINK
THAT THERE COULD BE SOME
DIFFICULTIES BOTH FOR YOU AND
FOR STAKEHOLDERS IN LOOKING AT.
HE SIGNIFICANTLY INCREASE NOW
AND THEN LOOKING AT INCREASING
FEES AGAIN IN A FEW YEARS. SO
YOU KNOW WEEK WE'VE SUGGEST YOU
MIGHT WANT TO CONSIDER ADOPTING
A MORE PERMANENT SOLUTION NOW
AND THERE'S REALLY TWO WAYS YOU
COULD DO THAT. THEY CLEANEST
WOULD BE TO ADOPT A FULL I'M
GOING SOLUTION NOW WITH I'M
GOING- THE INCREASES THAT AND
EXPENDITURE REDUCTIONS THAT
COVER THE WHOLE THE WHOLE THING
YOU'RE FACING- BUT THAT COULD
BE COMPLICATED TO TRY AND PUT
TOGETHER IN THE NEXT FEW MONTHS
PARTICULARLY IF YOU WANT TO
LOOK AT RESTRUCTURING THE FEE.
AS THE ADMINISTRATION'S
PROPOSED MAYBE LOOKING AT A
TIERED SYSTEM OR HAVE BEEN
EXPANDING THE FEATURE THOSE WHO
ARE PAYING RIGHT NOW LIKE NON
MOTORIZED BOAT USERS. ABOUT
OWNERS- SO ANOTHER OPTION YOU
COULD CONSIDER IS ADOPTING THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL FOR THE
SHORT TERM BUT ALSO ADOPTING A
SET OF TRIGGER. THE INCREASES
AND POTENTIALLY EXPENDITURE
REDUCTIONS AS WELL THAT WOULD
TAKE EFFECT IN A FEW YEARS SO
DO YOU HAVE THAT CONFIDENCE YOU
HAVE THAT BACKSTOP. THEY'VE GOT
AN ONGOING SOLUTION IN PLACE.
BUT IT ALSO WOULD ALLOW TIME
FOR THE BOATING COMMUNITY IN
THE ADMINISTRATION TO WORK OVER
THE NEXT FEW YEARS AND
POTENTIALLY COME FORTH WITH
ANOTHER. COMPROMISE ALTERNATIVE
TO PRESENT TO YOU THAT YOU
COULD PUT IN PLACE- SURE THAT
DEVELOPMENT BUT IT GIVES YOU
SOME CONFIDENCE THAT YOU'VE GOT
A MORE PERMANENT SOLUTION IN
PLACE IN THE BACKGROUND SHOULD
THAT NOT. BE ABLE TO
MATERIALIZE OVER THE NEXT FEW
YEARS. BUT WE THINK THINKING
ABOUT A MORE PERMANENT
SOLUTION. MIGHT MAKE SENSE IN
THIS CASE. FOR YOU A THAT MA'AM
OF THE WHO ARE. GOING TO GIVE
UP PUBLIC COMMENT AT THE END OF
THE HEARING MAY WANT TO. WEIGH
IN ON SOME OF THOSE OPTIONS I
KNOW THERE'S- A GOOD DEAL OF
INTEREST IN THE- BOATING
COMMUNITY ON- ON THIS
PARTICULAR ISSUE. DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE. GOOD MORNING MIKE
MCGINNIS FOR THE DEPARTMENT
FINANCE WE APPRECIATE THE-
ALEJO'S REMARKS ON THE- THE
SUBJECT THE AT THE WORK THAT ON
THIS BUT THE ADMINISTRATION
SUPPORTS THE PROPOSAL AS
SUBMITTED RATHER THAN BUILDING
IN NAY AT TRIGGER MECHANISM ARE
A LONG TERM SOLUTION AT THIS
POINT IN TIME TO ALLOW TIME TO
WORK WITH THE BOATING COMMUNITY
AS- DISCUSSED BY THE- SHE-
THANK YOU FOR THAT. AND- FLIP
SIDE OF IT THERE'S NO UP
ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS LET'S MOVE ON TO ISSUE
NUMBER TWO. THE A COMMUNITY
ENGAGEMENT RELEVANCY IN HISTORY
PROGRAM. WELL GOOD MORNING AT
SHERMAN BLOOMING COMMITTEE
MEMBER- MY NAME IS JIM NEWMAN
AND I'M A PROGRAM MANAGER WITH
THE DEPARTMENT OF PARKS AND
RECREATION I'M HERE TODAY IN
REFERENCE TO THE DEPARTMENTS-
COMMUNITY GAUGE RENT RELEVANCE
IN HISTORY PROGRAM REQUEST. IN
ITS REQUEST RESTING FOR FIVE
HUNDRED EIGHTY FIVE THOUSAND
AND I'M GOING FUNDING FROM THE
STATE PARKS AND RECREATION FUND
FOUR POSITIONS BEGINNING IN THE
NEXT FISCAL FISCAL YEAR TO
INSTITUTIONALIZE THE COMMUNITY
OUT REACH AND RELEVANCE AND
INTERPRETATION PILOT PROGRAMS.
VISITATIONS WILL MAINTAIN THE
EXISTING PROGRAM EFFORTS
INCLUDING THE SUCCESSFUL
SERVICE LEVELS. ESTABLISHED
DURING IMPLEMENTATION OF OUR
OTHER PROGRAMS. INCLUDING THE
PIONEERING PARTNERSHIPS WE HAVE
WITH THE PUBLIC HISTORY
PROGRAMS AT THE UNIVERSITY
CALIFORNIA'S BARBARA. AND YOU
SEE CALIFORNIA RIVERSIDE. ALL
TO IMPROVE THE ACCURACY AND THE
IMPLEMENTATION OF OUR CULTURE
EDUCATIONAL PROGRAMS. INSURING
THAT WE ARE ALSO REACHING OUT
ENGAGE IN INCORPORATING.
UNDERSERVED AND
UNDERREPRESENTED COMMUNITIES IN
ORDER TO CREATE THE MOST
EQUITABLE ACCURATE AND RELEVANT
PROGRAM WE CAN. THANK YOU TO
THE PROGRAM WILL BE TAKING
APPROACH ACROSS THE SYSTEM BY
DEVELOPING ADDITIONAL
PARTNERSHIPS WITH OTHER
UNIVERSITY CALIFORNIA AND CSU
PROGRAMS NONPROFIT PARTNERS
NGOS AND UNDERSERVED
COMMUNITIES. AND I'M AVAILABLE
FOR ANY QUESTIONS YOU HAVE
ABOUT THE PROGRAM. THANK YOU
BUT NOT SEEING ANY QUESTIONS
RIGHT NOW- LMAO. ALL THANK YOU
AGAIN RACHEL IT WAS WITH THE
ANALYST'S OFFICE WILL BE THE
PROPOSAL AND DIDN'T HAVE ANY
CONCERNS. I IMAGINE- FINANCE
DOESN'T HAVE ANY PROBLEM WITH
THIS. NO COMMENTS GREAT THANK
YOU. FIFTY ARE THERE- ANY OTHER
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS. BOB I
WOULD NOTE THAT- THE STAFF
RECOMMENDATION IS- THAT IF
THERE ARE NO- MEMBER QUESTIONS
OR- PUBLIC INPUT TO THE COUNTRY
THE- DIRECTION THE DEPARTMENT
IS GOING THAT TO DECIDE TO BE
CONSIDERED FOR THE VOTE ON THE
CALENDAR WHEN WE DO TAKE ACTION
IN THE FUTURE SO. OFTEN WE'LL
SEE IF THERE'S ANY PUBLIC
COMMENT. ON THE PARTICULAR
ISSUE AND- PENDING THAT WILL
MOVE ON TO ISSUE NUMBER THREE.
THE CATCH ALL CATEGORY FOR
CAPITAL OUTLAY PROJECTS. YEAH
HI GOOD MORNING- THIS IS BRIAN
DO WE STATE THAT WITH THE STATE
PARKS- I'M THE CHIEF OF
FACILITIES AND DEVELOPMENT.
WELL I ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS YOU
MAY HAVE ABOUT THE FIVE
PROJECTS IN THE IN THE BUDGET I
DIDN'T WANT TO- NO ONE SAYING
THE AGENDA- IDENTIFIES THE-
FUNDING AS GENERAL FUND FOR ALL
THESE PROJECTS AND JUST WANT TO
CLARIFY THAT THE- THE FIRST
ITEM FOR THE CYSTIC WIDE SYSTEM
ACQUISITION PROGRAM IS SIX
POINT THREE MILLION GENERAL
FUND WITH US SIX POINT THREE
MILLION BEING- REIMBURSEMENTS-
THE NEXT PROJECT FOR
CANDLESTICK POINT IS- TWO POINT
SIX MILLION FROM PROP SIXTY
EIGHT FUNDS. IN THE ROOM THERE
ARE THREE CONTINUING PROJECTS
FOR THE O. H. P. PROGRAM- AND
THEY'RE ALL FROM THE- OF HEAVY
VEHICLE TRUST FUND- I'M LOOKING
AT THE QUESTIONS YOU MAY HAVE
ABOUT THESE PROPOSALS THANK YOU
FOR POINTING. THAT OUT ARE
THERE ANY QUESTIONS. SEEING
ALEJO. THE PROPOSAL AND DON'T
ANY CONCERNS AND THIRTY
PERMANENT FUND. NO CONCERNS
THANK YOU- SIMILARLY- THIS ITEM
HAS A RECOMMENDATION THAT IT
FIRE THERE ARE NO- WOW
COMMITTEE CONCERNS- OR PUBLIC.
COMMENT CONCERNS SERVICES TO
CONSIDER FOR THE VOTE ONLY
CALENDAR WHEN IT RETURNS.
LITTLE MOVE ON NOW TO ISSUE
NUMBER FOUR. FIRE PREVENTION
WILD VIRUS. NUMBER RESISTANCE
ZONES I BELIEVE- THIS BILL- AB
THREE OH SEVEN FOUR WAS MS
FRIEDMAN IS THAT RIGHT. GREAT
THE GOOD BILL. IMPORTANT POLICY
DO WE HAVE A- YES GOOD MORNING
FROM NATURAL RESOURCES. YES
GOOD MORNING CHAIR MY NAME IS
JAY CHAMBERLAIN I'M THE CHIEF
THE NATURIST FORCES DIVISION
FOR CALIFORNIA STATE PARKS. AND
YES WE ARE HERE WHAT ARE
PROPOSAL HERE FOR THE EMBER
RESISTANT SOUND WEIRD- WITH-
OBVIOUSLY IN LIGHT OF THE
RECENT WILDFIRES THAT WE'VE HAD
IN IN RECENT YEARS THE- THE
IMPORTANCE OF STRUCTURAL
HARDING AND DEFENSIBLE SPACE.
HAS BECOME EVER MORE. OBVIOUS
AND URGENT AND SO THIS PROGRAM
WOULD GIVE US GIVE STATE PARKS
A DEDICATED RESOURCE TO ADDRESS
THAT PROBLEM AND AN ONGOING
BASIS. UP WE BELIEVE UNDER THIS
PROVISION WE'D BE ABLE TO TREAT
BETWEEN TWO HUNDRED AND FOUR
HUNDRED STRUCTURES PER YEAR. OF
THE EIGHTEEN HUNDRED THAT ARE
IN THE VERY HIGH END HIGH FIRE
RISK IS OWN CATEGORIES. THANK
YOU LMAO COMMENTS. YEAH WE
DON'T HAVE ANY CONCERNS WITH
THE PROPOSAL I THINK WE WOULD
JUST NOTE THAT THE SCOPE OF
WORK THAT THE DEPARTMENT IS
PROPOSING TO DO WITH THESE
FUNDS REALLY GOES BEYOND JUST
IMPLEMENTING THE REQUIREMENTS
OF AB THIRTY EIGHT SEVENTY FOUR
IT'S NOT JUST KIND OF THAT ZONE
AROUND THE PROPERTIES BUT
DEFENSIBLE SPACE MORE GENERALLY
BUT WE THINK THAT MAKES SENSE
AND IS AN IMPORTANT ACTIVITY
FOR THE DEPARTMENT TO
UNDERTAKE. THANK YOU THE PART
IN THE FINANCE. NO COMMENTS.
THANK YOU- UNDERSCORING THAT
THIS IS A PROGRAM THAT WILL
TAKE PLACE WITHIN THE STATE
PARK SYSTEM IT'S WORTH
OBSERVING- THAT- THERE ARE MANY
MANY STATE PARKS THAT FALL
WITHIN HIGH FIRE ZONE AREAS AND
TO- SO LET THIS ADDITIONAL
LAYER OF PROTECTION THAT- WILL
BE FORWARDED TO A TO THE PARKS
AND MANY OF THE BUILDINGS IN
THE PARK IS EXTREMELY IMPORTANT
MISTER BENNETT DID YOU HAVE A
QUESTION OR COMMENT YES THANK
YOU. AS THE L. A. O- POINTED
OUT- THIS ALSO PROVIDES FUNDING
TO GO BEYOND JUST A DEFENSIBLE
SPACE BUT ALSO TO SORT OF
ASSESS THE NEEDS OUT THERE WILL
THE DEPARTMENT BE COMING BACK
TO US- WELL AND HOW WITH THE
DEPARTMENT PRIORITIZE WHAT THE
NEXT SET OF NEEDS ARE IN TERMS
OF- DEFENDING OR AN IMPROVING
FIRE. PROJECT PREVENTION. THANK
YOU FOR THE QUESTION I THINK WE
ALL RECOGNIZE THE SCOPE AND
SCALE OF THE PROBLEM IS
EXTENSIVE AND WE AND OUR
IMPLEMENTATION NEEDS TO BE
ITERATIVE. I THINK WITH THE-
WITH THE NESTED PROPOSALS OF
WILDFIRE RESILIENCE MADE BY THE
ADMINISTRATION THIS YEAR WE'RE
GOING TO HAVE AN OPPORTUNITY TO
DO BOTH. IMPLEMENTATION AND
SIMULTANEOUS MONITORING OF THE
EFFICACY OF THAT WORK AND I DO
BELIEVE WE HAD TO SEPARATE
BEING ABLE TO RETURN- IN
SUBSEQUENT CONVERSATIONS WITH
OF A MORE COMPREHENSIVE
STRATEGY. THANK YOU. SMITH
FRIEDMAN. HAPPY TO SEE THIS
ITEM- IN FRONT OF THIS BODY IN
THE BUDGET. I JUST HAVE A QUICK
COMMENT WHICH IS THAT IT'S
REALLY IMPORTANT THAT THE THREE
AGENCIES HERE CAL FIRE. A STATE
PARKS THE ON THE BOARD OF
FORESTRY ALL WORK TOGETHER
BECAUSE THE GUIDELINES FOR THE
ZONE HAVEN'T BEEN. DESIGNED YET
COMPLETELY. IT'S IMPORTANT THAT
WHATEVER WORK IS DONE IT'S
CONSISTENT WITH. WHAT THE
GUIDELINES ARE GOING TO BE IN
SO THAT THE DIFFERENT GROUPS
ARE IN COMMUNICATION ABOUT.
WHAT THE IMPLEMENTATION WILL
LOOK LIKE AND ACTUALLY WHAT
YOU'RE GOING TO BE DIRECTING
HOMEOWNERS. AND PROPERTY OWNERS
AT TO DO. SO THAT'S THAT'S MY
ONLY COMMENT. THANK YOU. GREAT
TO. THANK YOU AND THE- THERE
APPEARED TO BE NO ADDITIONAL
COMMENTS WE WILL. MOVE ON TO
OUR NEXT PRESENTATION WHICH IS-
ISSUE FIVE FROM THE SAN
FRANCISCO BAY CONSERVATION AND
DEVELOPMENT COMMISSION. ALL.
THANK YOU TERRIBLE. I AM
WEARING GOLD AND EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR OF THE CDC AND SHOULD
MODERN TECHNOLOGY FAIL US MY
BACK UP FOR THE HEARING STEVE
GOLD BACK PART. SIMPLY PUT I
URGE YOU TO ADOPT THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL THE
CONTINUES FOR THREE YEARS BC
DC'S AUTHORIZE USE OF THE BAY
FEEL CLEAN UP AND ABATEMENT
FUND. TO PAY FOR COSTS
ASSOCIATED WITH OUR ENFORCEMENT
MANAGER AND ENFORCEMENT
TURKEY'S. IN TWENTY EIGHTEEN
THE LEGISLATURE AUTHORIZED THE
ESTABLISHMENT AND FUNDING OF
THESE TWO POSITIONS THROUGH THE
BAY FILL FOUGHT. AND THAT
AUTHORIZATION NEEDS TO BE
REVIEWED EVERY THREE YEARS DUE
TO THE VARIABILITY OF THE FUNDS
REVENUE STREAM. THESE RESOURCES
ARE CRITICAL FOR THE COMMISSION
TO CONTINUE TO FULFILL ITS
STATUTORY ENFORCEMENT
RESPONSIBILITIES. TO MOVE
FORWARD AFTER ADDRESSING
FINDINGS FROM THE STATE AUDITOR
ON THE COMMISSION'S ENFORCEMENT
PROGRAM. AND TO CONTINUE TO
IMPLEMENT ACTIONS IDENTIFIED IN
AB TWENTY EIGHT OH NINE BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER MULLIN. ABSENT
USING THE BAY FEEL CLEAN UP AN
ABATEMENT FUND TO FUND
ENFORCEMENT STAFF THE CDC WOULD
HAVE TO RE DIRECT CRITICAL
PERMITTING RESOURCES TO SUPPORT
THE ENFORCEMENT PROGRAM. AND
WITHOUT THESE TWO LEADERS THE
CDC NEVER WOULD HAVE BEEN ABLE
TO FIX AND ANY EFFECTIVE
PROGRAM AND CREATE OUR NEW
IMPROVED ONE. THE CDC'S
ENFORCEMENT EFFORTS WERE
SCATTERSHOT. INDIVIDUALS AND
THE AUDIT THAT WAS PUBLISHED
JUST AS WE WERE HIRING THESE
TWO INDIVIDUALS CORRECTLY NOTED
THAT THE CDC'S EFFORTS DID NOT
MEASURE UP TO THE NEEDS OF SAN
FRANCISCO BAY. THE COMMISSION
AND OUR STAFF SAID PUBLICLY AT
THAT TIME THAT WE APPRECIATED
THE RECOMMENDATIONS THAT THE
AUDITOR DIRECTED TOWARD THE CDC.
FOUR MONTHS AGO THE CDC
PROVIDED YOU WITH AN UPDATE ON
THE COMMISSION'S TREMENDOUS
PROGRESS WHICH IS DUE IN GREAT
PART TO THE LEADERSHIP PROVIDED
BY THE ENFORCEMENT MANAGER AND
DEDICATED ENFORCEMENT ATTORNEY.
WHO ARE PAID BY THE BAY FEEL
**** DURING THE PAST EIGHTEEN
MONTHS DAY IN OUR COMMISSIONS
ENFORCEMENT COMMITTEE
ESTABLISHED A SERIES OF
REGULATORY POLICY AND PRACTICE
CHANGES THAT PROMOTE
DETERRENCE. AND ENSURE
TRANSPARENT CONSISTENT AND FAIR
APPROACH TO ALL ENFORCEMENT
CASES THESE CHANGES INCLUDE
WHOLESALE OR PARTIAL ADOPTION
OF ALMOST ALL OF THE AUDIT'S
RECOMMENDATIONS DIRECTED TO DC
DC. THE ENFORCEMENT TEAM IS
ADOPTED SPECIFIC WRITTEN
PROCEDURES EFFECTIVELY TRACKS
CASES RESPONSE TO VIOLATIONS
REPORTED IN A TIMELY WAY AND
HAS DEVELOPED CASE RESOLUTION
MILESTONES ALL OF WHICH WERE
DEVELOPED THROUGH PUBLIC
PROCESSES. THE COMMISSION IS
CONSIDERING A NEW
ADMINISTRATIVE SCHOOL PILOT
PENALTY POLICY OUR OLDEST CASES
ARE BEING RESOLVED IN OUR CASE
PRIORITY SYSTEM HAS BEEN MADE
LESS COMPLEX THE COMMISSION IS
RECEIVING QUARTERLY UPDATES ON
PROGRAMS PROGRESS. REGARDING
ASSEMBLY MEMBER MULLINS AB
TWENTY EIGHT OH NINE. OUR
ENFORCEMENT TEAM HAS
IMPLEMENTED WRITTEN CASE REVIEW
PROCEDURES THAT DEFINE WHO HOW
AND WHEN MANAGEMENT REVIEWS
ENFORCEMENT STAFF DECISIONS IN
ADDITION WRITTEN CASE
MANAGEMENT PROCEDURES SPECIFY
TIME FRAMES WITHIN WHICH
ENFORCEMENT CASES NEED TO BE
RESOLVED FURTHER THE CDC'S NEW
ADMINISTRATIVE CIVIL PENALTY
POLICY INCLUDES A MATRIX TO
CALCULATE CIVIL PENALTIES IT
INCORPORATES HOW BC DC WILL
ASSESS MULTIPLE VIOLATION
PENALTIES BY TYPE OF VIOLATION.
BOTH THE BILL CONSISTENT SCENE
ENABLE TRANSPARENCY SO LET ME
PROVIDE YOU WITH JUST A FEW
STATISTICS DURING THE PAST
CALENDAR YEAR THE NUMBER OF
PENDING ENFORCEMENT CASES HAS
DROPPED FROM. TWO HUNDRED
EIGHTY FOUR TO TWO HUNDRED
ELEVEN. THE NUMBER OF OUR
OLDEST CASES HAS DROPPED BY
HALF. THREE TIMES MORE CASES
WERE CLOSED IN TWENTY TWENTY
COMPARED TO TWENTY NINETEEN.
MOST IMPORTANT ONE THIRD OF ALL
PENDING CASES ARE BEING
INVESTIGATED OR IN THE PROCESS
OF BEING RESOLVED. I WANT TO
CLOSE BY SAYING THAT THESE
ACCOMPLISHMENTS HAVE OCCURRED
WHILE THE ENFORCEMENT STAFF AND
COMMISSIONS ENFORCEMENT
COMMITTEE EXTENDED AMEND THIS
EFFORT TO CREATE VIRTUALLY A
NEW PROGRAM. NOW THAT MOST OF
THE NECESSARY PROCESS CHANGES
HAVE BEEN ACCOMPLISHED WE
FORECAST THAT MORE ENFORCEMENT
CASES WILL BE TAKEN UP AND
RESOLVED WHICH WE HOPE WILL
DETER FUTURE VIOLATIONS. BUT WE
COULD NOT HAVE ACCOMPLISHED
THESE SUCCESSES WITHOUT
ENFORCEMENT MANAGER AND
ENFORCEMENT ATTORNEY AND WE
CANNOT CONTINUE TO APPROVED
WITHOUT THEIR CONTINUED
EMPLOYMENT IN PARTNERSHIP WITH
OUR PERMITTING T. FOR THESE
REASONS I URGE YOU TO ADOPT THE
ADMINISTRATION'S BUDGET CHANGE
PROPOSAL HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS. THANK YOU SIR-
NOTING THAT THE OUR STAFF. FIVE
COMMENTS THAT THE PROPOSAL. AND
TRAILER BILL DIRECTLY UNDER
CUT. ASSEMBLY MEMBER MULLINS
EFFORTS AND THE AUDITOR'S
RECOMMENDATION- I BELIEVE FOR A-
MISTER MARLAND IS AVAILABLE
REMOTELY AND WISHES TO ASK SOME
QUESTIONS MR MILLER ARE YOU
THERE. ASSEMBLY MEMBER. YOU'RE
ON MUTE I'M TOLD. AREA AT THE
VERY HIGH ENERGY TELL SOMEBODY
ELSE MUTED ME JUST FOR THE
RECORD. I DO NOT KNOW HAS. OKAY
AND CAN GRANT MISTER CHAIR TO
ROUTE FORTY TWO OH TWO AGAIN I
WISH I COULD BE WITH ALL OF YOU
IN PERSON THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SHARE JUST A
COUPLE OF THOUGHTS AND THANK
YOU TO EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR GOLD
BANDS WHO HAS MADE A EXCELLENT
PROGRESS YET I AM CONCERNED
THAT ONCE AGAIN THAT B. C. B.
C. BUDGET PRESENTED TODAY
ALLOWS THE CONTINUED USE OF THE
BAY FELL CLEAN UP IN A BAY EVEN
FIND TO FIND. ENFORCEMENT STAFF
SALARIES FOR MEMBERS- BENEFIT
THIS IS THE FUN WERE FINES AND
PENALTIES COLLECTED THROUGH B.
C. B. S.'S ENFORCEMENT ACTIVITY
ARE DEPOSITED. AS BACKGROUND I
CALL THIS ISSUE OUT OF THE
TWENTY EIGHTEEN BUDGET PROCESS.
D. O. F. PROPOSED THEN AS IT
HAS DONE IT AGAIN. THE SAME
APPROACH I'M TROUBLED THAT WERE
BEING ASKED ONCE AGAIN TO
APPROVE ENFORCEMENT STAFF
FUNDING BY AND- BY USING
ENFORCEMENT PROCEEDS.
ESSENTIALLY STAFF WOULD BE
TASKED WITH GENERATING THEIR
OWN SALARIES. THIS IS A CANNED
HIRING MORE POLICE OFFICERS BY
ISSUE A WARRANT CITATIONS.
THERE'S A LOT OF HISTORY HERE
AND I DON'T WANT TO GO THROUGH
ALL THE STEPS YOU HEARD ABOUT
THAT LEGISLATION I AUTHORED
WHICH WAS THE RESULT OF A
BIPARTISAN. STATE AUDIT
IDENTIFIED A NUMBER OF ISSUES
AROUND THE CDC'S ENFORCEMENT
STRATEGY AND YOU HEARD THAT
PROGRESS IS BEING MADE AND I
APPLAUD THE COMMISSION. I
APPLAUD THE EXECUTIVE YET I'M
VERY CONCERNED ABOUT THIS
PERVERSE INCENTIVES ON HOW THIS
FUND IS BEING YOU IS ONE OF THE
AUDITORS KEY RECOMMENDATIONS.
IS THAT THE LEGISLATURE CLARIFY
THE INTENDED USE OF THE BAY
FEEL CLEAN UP IN A BAY EVEN
FINANCE FOR THE PHYSICAL CLEAN
UP OF THE BAY. RATHER THAN
ENFORCEMENT STAFF SALARIES I'M
TROUBLED THAT THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE FULLY AWARE OF THE
AUDITOR'S RECOMMENDATIONS IS
MOVING. IN THE OPPOSITE
DIRECTION WE PROPOSE TRAILER
BILL LANGUAGE THAT CODIFIES
THAT EXISTING ENFORCEMENT
ACTIVITIES ARE ELIGIBLE USED TO
THE BAY FELT CLEAN UP AN
ABATEMENT FUND. IF THE
ADMINISTRATION IS SERIOUS ABOUT
TACKLING CLIMATE CHANGE AND I
BELIEVE THAT THEY ARE. THEN OUR
RESOURCE TO AGENCIES NEED TO BE
PROPERLY FUNDED AND STAFFED.
AND I SAY THIS WITH THE NIGHT
OF THE FUTURE WE NEED B. C. D.
C. AS A TRUSTED. AND RESPECTED
REGULATORY PARTNER THE ISSUE
FOR OUR GENERATION IS CLIMATE
CHANGE AND FOR B. C. B. C.'S
PURPOSES SEALEVEL RISE. AS ONE
OF THE REGULATORY AGENCIES HAVE
TO ADDRESS THE LEVEL RISE B.
CDC NEEDS TO BE ON SOLID
FOOTING MOVING FORWARD I AM
PLEASED. WITH THE WORK THE CDC
HAS UNDERTAKEN TO BRACE THE
AUDITOR'S RECOMMENDATIONS OF
BELIEVE THE ORGANIZATION NEEDS
STABILITY IN ITS RESOURCES. AND
TO THAT END I PLAN ON
ADVOCATING FOR THESE
ENFORCEMENT POSITIONS- THAT
THEY BE FUNDED THROUGH THE
GENERAL FUND. I DO HAVE A
QUESTION FOR DEPARTMENT FINANCE
I BELIEVE WE HAVE A DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE RAP- AVAILABLE. AND
REALLY IT'S JUST- TO BETTER
UNDERSTAND THE THOUGHT PROCESS.
AROUND THE USE OF THIS FIGHT
AND- TO FUNDS- STAFF SALARIES
AND ARE THERE OTHER STATE
REGULATORY AGENCIES. THAT HAVE
THIS MODEL BILL TEN USING
PENALTIES TO FIND STAFF. DO WE
HAVE- EXAMPLES OF THAT IN IN
STATE GOVERNMENT. DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE. THANK YOU KAREN
MEMBERS MARION KAPLAN WITH
FINANCE. I. SO TO ADDRESS YOUR
TWO PART QUESTION. AND THERE
ARE OTHER EXAMPLES OF
DEPARTMENTS USING SPECIAL FUNDS
TO FIND ENFORCEMENT I WILL
POINT YOU TO. FILMATION'S I
USED OF THE VIOLATIONS THAT'S
HOW. AT OF THE COASTAL
CONSERVANCY FIND AS WELL AS THE
DEPARTMENT OF WILDLIFE ISSUES
AT THAT POSITION GAME
PRESERVATION PATENT. I COULD
YOU PLEASE REPEAT THE OTHER
PIECE OF YOUR- WELL WHAT I'M
WHAT I'M TRYING TO GET AT IS
THE RATIONALE FOR THE PROPOSED
TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE ALLOWING
THE USE OF THE ENGAGEMENT FIND
FOR ENFORCEMENT STAFF. STOP
ABSOLUTELY AND THANK YOU FOR
THE QUESTION- THE RATIONALE
BEHIND THAT USE OF THE BAY FELT
CLEAN AND ABATEMENT FIND FOR
ENFORCEMENT ACTIVITIES IS- OUR
INTERPRETATION OF GOVERNMENT
CODE SECTION SIX SIX SIX FOUR
ONE POINT NINE THAT- IDENTIFIES.
COSTS SHOULD BE RECOUPED-
WITHIN THAT I THAN MEANT. OF
THAT FINES AND FEES. OKAY I'M
GOING TO REITERATE MY
OPPOSITION TO THIS TYPE OF
FINANCING FOR REGULATORY
AGENCIES AND WOULD SUGGEST THAT
FORMER FINANCE HE- THE AUDITORS.
APARTMENT THE RESULTS OF THE-
AUDITORS RECOMMENDATIONS. AND I
THINK IT'S NOT GOOD GOVERNMENT
IT FURTHER ERODES TRUST AND- I
WANT TO MAKE SURE THE CDC HAS
FULL PUBLIC TRUST MOVING
FORWARD JUST A FINAL COMMENT-
MISTER CHAIR AND THEN I'LL LET
THIS ISSUE GO AND LOOK FORWARD
TO WORKING WITH THE L. F. AND-
OUR PARTNERS ON THE SENATE SIDE
AS WELL ON THIS- RELATIVELY
SMALL AMOUNT OF MONEY FRANKLY.
OFFER THE IMPORTANT WORK THAT
IS BEING DONE- BUT LAST YEAR IN
THE GOVERNOR'S MAY REVISE WHEN
ALL STATE AGENCY BUDGETS EITHER
WORST THINK FLATTER REDUCE THE
CDC'S BUDGET- ACTUALLY WENT UP
BY SIX HUNDRED AND SEVENTY
THREE. THOUSAND DOLLARS I LATER
LEARNED THAT AMOUNT WAS
SETTLED- FOR A PUBLIC RECORDS
ACT LAWSUIT THAT B. C. B. C.
LOST APPROXIMATELY THREE
HUNDRED THIRTY ONE THOUSAND OF
THAT. THROUGH THE DEPARTMENT OF
JUSTICE FOR THEIR COSTS AT
APPROXIMATELY 300-402-0002 PAY
FOR THE PLAINTIFF'S ATTORNEY.
THE STATE AUDITS ESTIMATED COST
WAS JUST OVER THREE HUNDRED
THOUSAND DOLLARS ADDING THAT
THE SIX HUNDRED SEVENTY THREE
THOUSAND DOLLARS FROM THE PIER
A LOSS HE BRINGS US CLOSE TO A
MILLION DOLLARS IN TAXPAYER
FUNDS HAD BEEN SPENT SO FAR AS
A RESULT OF THIS ABATEMENT FIND
ISSUE. ADD TO THAT THE NUMBER
OF THE CDC STAFF HOURS AT
LEGISLATIVE STAFF OUR SINCE
TWENTY EIGHTEEN THAT HAVE BEEN
DEDICATED TO TRYING TO SOLVE
THIS ISSUE AND I'M CONCERNED
THAT WE HAVE A CASE OF BEING
PENNY WISE AND POUND FOOLISH
I'LL BE ADVOCATING. FUNDING
THROUGH THE GENERAL FUND THANK
YOU MISTER. CHAIR AND MEMBERS
FOR YOUR TIME. THANK YOU. FOR
MUCH FOR. YOUR YOUR COMMENTS.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER MULLIN- ARE
THERE ANY ADDITIONAL I DON'T
THINK WE HEARD FROM ALEJO LET'S
MAKE SURE WE HEAR FROM LA- AND
TO. THANK YOU WE DON'T HAVE ANY
COMMENTS ON THIS ISSUE ALL
RIGHT THANK YOU ARE THERE ANY
OTHER. QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS.
MISTER BENNETT JUST WANTED THEM
I THINK ASSEMBLYMEMBER MULLINS
COMMENTED- IT. RAISES THE ISSUE
OF TRUST- HI I THINK IF WE'VE
SEEN REPEATEDLY WHEN PEOPLE
FEEL LIKE THE FINE IS GOING TO
FUND THE POSITION THERE'S AN
INHERENT CONFLICT OF INTEREST-
IN TERMS OF ANALYZING WHETHER
THERE IS A VIOLATION OR NOT AND
WHAT THE FINE SHOULD BE SO I
THINK IT'S A IT'S A WISE-
INVESTMENT ON OUR PART TO TRY
TO BUILD THAT KIND OF TRUST- BY
ELIMINATING THAT KIND OF
CONFLICT. THANK YOU. SANTA
WE'RE GOING TO BE HOLDING THIS
ISSUE OPEN AS WE ARE WITH. THE
ENTIRE AGENDA TODAY AND I HOPE
WHEN THIS COMES BACK. APSE WILL
OF- BE ABLE TO HEAR OF A MORE
DEFINITIVE PLAN FOR HOW THE- A
B. C. D. C. CAN MOVE FORWARD-
IN A WAY. THAT- ADDRESSES THE
VERY IMPORTANT ISSUES THAT
ASSEMBLY MEMBER MULLIN HAS
RAISED. STAFF THERE SAID
NOTHING FURTHER WE WILL MOVE ON
TO THE DEPARTMENT COME FIRST
CONSERVATION CONVERSATION THAT
WOULD BE IF. OUR DEPARTMENT-
HAVE ISSUE FIXED CONTINUATION
OF FUNDING FOR REGULATORY FIELD
INSPECTION. THANK YOU TERRIBLE
THURMOND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE I'M I'M DAVID CHIU
MANAGING DIRECTOR OF THE
DEPARTMENT OF CONSERVATION FOR
APPRECIATE THE OPPORTUNITY TO
BE WITH YOU TODAY TO SHARE THE
DEPARTMENT'S BUDGET CHANGE
PROPOSALS HI THIS YEAR WE HAVE
THREE SOFT START WITH ISSUE SIX
WHICH IS THE CALIFORNIA
GEOLOGICAL ENERGY MANAGEMENT
DIVISION OR CALDERON. TO MAKE
PERMANENT BASELINE FUNDING
INCREASE OF JUST OVER THREE
POINT NINE MILLION DOLLARS FROM
THE OIL GAS AND GEOTHERMAL
ADMINISTRATIVE FUND. ALTHOUGH
MAINTAIN TWELVE ONE. INITIALLY
APPROVED IN FISCAL YEAR.
NINETEEN FOR UNLIMITED TERM. IF
YOU'RE A PC PC TO MAKE
DECISIONS IRMA. NO POSITION
ACCORDING REQUEST AS THAT GRANT
BACK IN YEAR EIGHTEEN NINETEEN.
BUT THESE POSITIONS HAVE BEEN
REALLY IMPORTANT MAY HAVE
HELPED HOW JAM CONTINUE TO MEET
THE GOVERNOR'S AND
LEGISLATURE'S OBJECTIVES FOR
MAINTAINING PROGRESS TOWARD
IMPROVED OVERSIGHT OIL
PRODUCTION IN CALIFORNIA.
REJECTED PUBLIC HEALTH AND
SAFETY AND ENVIRONMENTAL
QUALITY AND MAINTAIN THE
HIGHEST REGULATORY STANDARDS IN
THE COUNTRY. THE CAPACITY ADDED
THREE THESE POSITIONS HELPS CAL
JAM IN PAIN STRONG FIELD
PRESENTS FOR INCREASED
INSPECTION ENFORCEMENT. AND
CONTINUE PROGRESS FOR
WITNESSING REQUIRED TEST WELL
WORKS BUILD ANOTHER ACTIONS. MS
ALL HELP ASSESS AND MITIGATE
URBAN ENCROACHMENT ON OIL AND
GAS FIELDS AND WORK WITH LOCAL
AGENCIES TO PROTECT WATER
RESOURCES. MAKING IT PETITIONS
PERMANENTLY WILL HELP COUNTY
I'M SUSTAIN THIS PROGRESS. GLAD
TO TAKE ANY QUESTIONS ON THIS
ITEM. MISTER SMITH HAS A
QUESTION THANK YOU- IN REGARDS
TO THE EMPLOYEES OF- BCP CLAIMS
pOF A TWENTY FIVE POSITIONS OR
AUTHORIZED IN LAST YEAR'S
BUDGET. BUT YOU'VE ONLY HIRED
FOR. AND THEY'RE STILL TWENTY
ONE VACANCIES BUT NOW YOU'RE
ASKING FOR I THINK ANOTHER
TWENTY ONE POSITIONS IS THAT
THE SAME TWENTY ONE THAT YOU
HAVE BEEN HIRED FOR THE LAST
TWO YEARS. AND WHY IS THERE
SUCH A TURNOVER OR HARD TIME
HIRING PEOPLE IN THAT
DEPARTMENT- NEED PHYSICIANS
WERE ALREADY IN PLACE- THE
TWENTY ONE THAT YOU'RE
REFERRING TO ARE UP FROM LAST
YEAR'S PCP. I'M WE HAVE
CONDUCTED. A AND- YEAH- MY
HIRING PROCESS WE- WE HAVE
APPLICATIONS AND WE'RE
REVIEWING THOSE APPLICATIONS
AND WILL BE GET INTERVIEWING
YEAH. ALSO THOSE THOSE TWENTY
WONDERFUL ACTORS BECAUSE HE
PAID IT YES TWENTY ONE IS FROM
THE FISCAL YEAR EIGHTEEN
NINETEEN THREE YEAR TEMPORARY
POSITIONS. AND- CAL JAM STILL
SITTING ON SIXTY UNDERGROUND
INJECTION CONTROL PROJECTS.
THAT ARE MORE THAN TWO YEARS
OLD AGE- THAT NICK INDUSTRY IS
PAYING FOR THOSE WHY IS IT
TAKING SO LONG TO GET THEIR
PERMITS APPROVED. I'M NOT SURE
ABOUT THAT NUMBER I CAN I CAN
ASK YOU QUESTIONS AND TOOK TO.
FIND THAT NUMBER HE'S ON THE ON
THE LINE HERE. A GOOD MORNING
CHAIRMAN BLOOM ASSEMBLY
MEMBERS- YES THERE THERE HAS
BEEN A BACKLOG OF YOU I SEE
PROJECTS THROUGH FOR A VARIETY
OF REASONS- SEVERAL ART WERE
WAITING INFORMATION FROM
OPERATORS. THE OTHERS ARE UNDER
ENVIRONMENTAL OR SEEK A REVIEW.
AND THEN WE DO HAVE A NEW
POLICY A PROCESS IN PLACE. POST
NATIONAL LAB IN THE DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE AUDIT THAT WAS JUST
COMPLETED. FURTHERMORE WE GO
DOWN MORE. FAMILIAR PATTERSON
DID YOU HAVE QUESTIONS. ONE ON
THIS I'M I'M GONNA FOR SOME
UNSPECIFIED HERE- SO MY
UNDERSTANDING IS- YOU'RE
REQUESTING AN ADDITIONAL FOUR
POINT EIGHT MILLION- WHAT
PHASED IN OVER THE NEXT THREE
YEARS FOR TWENTY SIX NEW
POSITION. I THE REQUESTED FOUR
MILLION IN LAST YEAR'S BUDGET
FOR TWENTY FIVE POSITIONS FOR
THE SAME SCOPE OF WORK OUTLINED
IN THIS YEAR'S BUDGET IT'S
JAMES. OF THE TWENTY FIVE
POSITIONS APPROVED. LAST YEAR
ONLY FOUR HAVE BEEN HIRED. SO
WHAT HAVE YOU DONE WITH THE
FREE MONEY FOR THOSE POSITIONS
AND WHY DO THEY WHY DO YOU NEED
TWENTY. SIX MORE WHEN YOU'VE
ONLY. HEARD FOR IN OTHER WORDS.
THAT THAT THOSE WHO ARE PAYING
FOR YOUR OPERATION. WITH THEIR
FEET. HAVE PUT UP SUBSTANTIAL
NEW. RESOURCES. AND YET YOU
ONLY HIRED FOR. I GUESS. BACK
IN THE MONEY SOMEWHERE MR
PATTERSON- AND THAT ISSUE IS
ISSUE SEVEN- WORK CURRENTLY ON
ISSUE SIX I THINK WE'LL BE
MOVING UP PRETTY QUICKLY IT IS
ONEROUS YOU SEVEN SO IF YOU
COULD HOLD TO YOUR QUESTION-
AND A BAND FOR JUST A MOMENT.
TO I'M DO THAT BUT I WAS GIVEN
A CONTEXT TO THE- YOU SEE ARE
YOU I SEE PERMITS BUT I'LL I'LL
I'LL DO THAT OKAY WELL WE CAN
YOU KNOW I THINK WHAT WHAT
MIGHT BE HELPFUL MS FRIEDMAN-
YOU'LL LET ME KNOW IF- YOU ONE
INTERJECT QUESTION NOW BUT
MAYBE WE CAN MOVE THROUGH ALL.
THREE OF THESE ISSUES AND THEN-
ASK QUESTIONS COLLECTIVELY
ROUNDELS. SO IF YOU LIKE TO
CONTINUE I DON'T KNOW IF YOU
HAVE FINISHED YOUR PRESENTATION
ON ISSUE SIX I THINK SO- BUT
YOU CAN MOVE. IT ON TO ISSUE
SEVEN AND EIGHT. AND OKAY GREAT.
CERTAINLY YES ALL MOVE ON ISSUE
SEVEN. I'M SO ISSUE SEVEN IS
THE PROPOSAL ALSO FOR GALGIANI.
I REQUEST TEAM TWENTY SIX
POSITIONS ON THE BASELINE
INCREASE OF JUST OVER FOUR
POINT EIGHT MILLION DOLLARS
FROM THE OIL GAS AND GEOTHERMAL
ADMINISTRATIVE FUNDS. AND IT
WILL BE PHASED IN OVER THREE
YEARS. THE LIKE THE FIRST
PROPOSAL THIS ONE ALSO HELPS
CAL JAM CONTINUE TRANSFORMING
ITS MISSION TO FOCUS ON PUBLIC
HEALTH AND SAFETY. AND
ENVIRONMENTAL QUALITY. OVER THE
LAST EIGHTEEN MONTHS UNDER THE-
DIRECTION OF SUPERVISOR TOOK
HOW YOUNG HAS MADE GREAT
STRIDES IN THIS TRANSFORMATION.
HOWEVER THERE IS MUCH MORE WORK
TO BE DONE. THE PROPOSAL WELL
AS CISCO GERMAN CONTINUING ON
THAT PATH. PLEASE THIS PROPOSAL
WELL INCREASED STAFF PRESENCE
IN THE FIELD TO PERFORM
INSPECTIONS. AND CONTINUE THE
QUEST TO WITNESS ALL OIL AND
GAS OPERATIONS ESPECIALLY THOSE
TAKING PLACE AT CRITICAL WELL
SITES. AND NEAR SENSITIVE
RECEPTORS. THIS INCLUDES ALSO
COLLECTING INFORMATION AND GIS
DATA. FOR RELATED FACILITIES
AND PIPELINES. THE WOULD ALL
ALLOW TO CONTAIN IMPLEMENTATION
OF AT FIVE FIFTY ONE. AB TEN
FIFTY SEVEN AND ENSURE
SUFFICIENT FUNDING IS IN PLACE
SO THE STATE DOES NOT HAVE TO
ASSUME LIABILITY FOR ORPHANED
OR ABANDONED WELL RELATED
FACILITY. THE PROPOSAL HELPS
ENSURE IDYLLWILD MANAGEMENT
PLANS. ARE SUBMITTED IN A
TIMELY AND ACCURATE MANNER
STRAIGHT HELLO JIM HORSEMEN
PROGRAM INCLUDING ISSUE ONCE OF
ENFORCEMENT ORDERS FROM THE
SUPERVISOR OR THE PROPOSAL
HELPS DEVELOP PRIORITIES TO
PLUG AND ABANDON WELLSITE
INDEPENDENT. WRESTLING DEREK.
SENSITIVE RECEPTORS. THE
PROPOSAL ALSO TRêN THROUGH
INCREASED DATA INTEGRITY AND
SUPPORT OF THE PUBLIC HEALTH
RULE MAKING PROCESS CURRENTLY
UNDERWAY AS WELL AS FUEL FUTURE
RULEMAKING. AND FINALLY THIS
PROPOSAL HELPED IMPLEMENT THE
GOVERNOR'S EXECUTIVE ORDER TO
DECARBONISE THE TRANSPORTATION
SECTOR. THIS IS A THREE YEAR
IMPLEMENTATION THAT CONSISTS OF
TWELVE POSITIONS IN YOUR ONE.
TEN PHYSICIANS IN YEAR TWO AND
FOUR POSITIONS IN THE FINAL
YEAR. WE DECIDED TO TAKE A MORE
MEASURED APPROACH WITH THIS
PROPOSAL DUE TO THE CONTINUING
ECONOMIC STRUGGLES RESULTING
FROM THE COPE WITH PANDEMIC.
ANOTHER THEATER CRITICAL
POSITIONS FOR THE EVOLUTION OF
CAL JAM. I WILL MOVE ON TO
ISSUE EIGHT. ISSUE RELATED THE
PROPOSAL FOR THE CALIFORNIA
GEOLOGICAL SURVEY OR CDS. THIS
IS PERFECT FOR POSITION AND A
THREE YEAR LIMITED TERM
INCREASE OF THREE MILLION
DOLLARS. FROM THE STRONG MOTION
INSTRUMENTATION AND SEISMIC
HAZARDS MAPPING FONG. THE
REQUESTED FOR A THREE YEAR
PILOT PROGRAM WITHIN CGS TO
DEVELOP THREE DIMENSIONAL
SUBSURFACE GEOLOGIC MAPPING
WHICH WILL HELP THE STATE WITH
SEVERAL IMPORTANT PROJECTS. THE
FIRST IS SEISMIC MAPPING OF
FAULTS AND FAULT CONDITIONS
THIS WILL HELP YOU EVALUATE THE
POTENTIAL FOR GROUND MOTION
WHICH IS THE FORMATION
LANDSLIDES AND LIQUEFACTION.
AND HOW THAT MANIFESTS
POTENTIALLY IN RISKS TO
BUILDING INFRASTRUCTURE. AND
NATURAL AND CULTURAL RESOURCES.
WELL ALSO FROM GROUND WATER
RECHARGE MAPPING ENHANCEMENTS
TO SUPPORT SICK MY
IMPLEMENTATION SPECIFICALLY
LOOKING AT AQUIFER CONDITIONS
AND THEIR CAPACITY AND QUALITY
IN THEIR OPPORTUNITY FOR
RECHARGE. THE MAPPING EFFORT
WOULD PROVIDE MINERAL RESOURCE
EVALUATIONS LOOKING AT
EVERYTHING FROM AGGREGATE WHICH
IS LITERALLY THE FOUNDATION OF
OUR COMMUNITIES JUST REPEATED
MINERALS NEEDED FOR HIGH TECH
INDUSTRIES AND PRODUCTS. THE
PROPOSAL ALSO INCLUDES ENERGY
RESOURCE EVALUATIONS TO
GENERATE MAPS OF OIL AND GAS
FIELDS TO HELP GET THE STATE ON
PAR WITH THE IDEA THAT THE
INDUSTRY USE THAT. AND HELP BUT
BETTER EVALUATE PROJECT
PROPOSALS LOOKING AT KEY
FACTORS SUCH AS SEISMIC RISK
OR- IMPACT THE AQUIFER'S. AND
THIS IS PARTICULARLY IMPORTANT
AS WE SEE MORE PLUGGING AND
ABANDONING OF WELLS TO MAKE
SURE THAT THAT THAT IS DONE THE
STATE MATTER. THE OTHER
COMPONENT TO THE ENERGY
PORTFOLIO IN THIS IN THIS
PROPOSAL IS TO LOOK AT I'M WAY
TO ENHANCE THE EVALUATIONS OF
THAT. OF THE GEO THERMAL
OPPORTUNITIES IN CALIFORNIA.
FINALLY THIS TYPE OF MAPPING
CAN ALSO BE USED TO ASSESS
CARBON STORAGE OPPORTUNITIES IN
THE FUTURE LOOKING AT THE
POTENTIAL FOR DEEP STORAGE OF
CAPTURED CARBON IN CALIFORNIA.
AND HELPING US MEET THE RECENT
EXECUTIVE ORDERS TO ACHIEVE
CARBON NEUTRALITY RIGHT TWENTY
FORTY FIVE. THESE MAPS ARE
IMPORTANT BECAUSE THEY PROVIDE
A GREAT DEAL OF SCIENCE WE
DON'T HAVE TODAY IN CAN BE
UTILIZED BY MANY STATE AGENCIES
SUCH AS THE DEPARTMENT OF WATER
RESOURCES STATE WATER RESOURCES
CONTROL BOARD. CALTRANS
HELLFIRE AND HELLO YES. THESE
MAPS GIVE ALL OF THE AGENCIES A
COMMON PLATFORM TO COLLABORATE
ON IMPORTANT STATE ISSUES. HI
THIS BECAUSE MY PRESENTATIONS
AND I'M I'M GLAD TO TAKE ANY
QUESTIONS ON ANY OF YOUR SHOTS.
THANK YOU SO WELL LET'S RETURN
TO OUR MISTER PATTERSON. THANK
YOU THANK WAS CHAIR OF. AND LET
ME SET THIS UP IN THE AGAIN.
YOUR YOU'RE REQUESTING FOUR
POINT EIGHT MILLION PHASE IN
OVER THREE YEARS FOR TWENTY SIX
NEW POSITIONS THE REQUESTED
FOUR MILLION IN LAST YEAR'S
BUDGET FOR TWENTY FIVE NEW
POSITIONS A CENTURY THE SAME
SCOPE OF WORK OUTLINED THIS
YEAR'S BUDGET. THE TWENTY FIVE
POSITION APPROVED LAST YEAR
ONLY FOUR HAVE BEEN HIGHER. SO
I THINK THE FIRST QUESTION IS
WHY ARE YOU COMING. WITH
ADDITIONAL REQUEST THESE.
OPERATIONS IN THESE PERMIT
HOLDERS. FOR THESE ADDITIONAL.
THE POSITIONS AND IN THE
CONTEXT OF ALL OF THIS OVER THE
PAST FEW YEARS. CALTRANS BUDGET
HAS NEARLY TRIPLED. YEP PERMIT
DELAYS ARE WORSE THAN ANYONE.
SINCE TWENTY NINE. ONLY ONE
UNDERGROUND INJECTION PERMIT
HAS BEEN. UNDERSTAND YOU WERE
SITTING ON SIXTEEN YOU ICE. SO
FIRST OF ALL WHAT HAVE YOU DONE
WITH RESOURCES. IF YOU DID NOT
HIGHER ON THOSE TWENTY FIVE YOU
WANT TO KIND. AND SECONDLY WHAT
IS TAKING. TO I SEE PERMITS.
ALL OF THIS BY THE WAY FOR BY
THOSE WHO ARE IN. THAT THE
BUSINESS OF PURPA PROVIDING
ENERGY AND SO WHAT THEY ARE
DOING IS PAYING EVER INCREASING
FEES FOR WHAT APPEARS TO BE
SLOW OR NON EXISTENT PROCESSING
WHAT'S TAKEN SO LONG. WELL
FIRST OF ALL ON YOUR QUESTION
REGARDING THE HIRING AS I
MENTIONED EARLIER- WE HAVE
BASICALLY TAKEN AND-
APPLICATIONS FOR ALL OF THE
POSITIONS BECAUSE TEENS HAVE
CLOSED- AND AS YOU MENTIONED WE
HAVE HIRED FOR BUT WE ARE ALSO
IN THE PROCESS OF SCORING THOSE
THOSE APPLICATIONS. FROM THOSE
CANDIDATES AND WE WILL BEGIN
INTERVIEWING INTERVIEWING FOR
THOSE POSITIONS YEAH SO YES WE
WILL ADMIT THAT WE WERE A
LITTLE SLOW OUT OF THE GATE-
HIRING THOSE POSITIONS- YOU
KNOW WE HAD TO PAUSE AND FIGURE
OUT HOW TO DO THAT YEAH IN IN
THE COBIT ENVIRONMENT IN THE IN
THE VIRTUAL ENVIRONMENT. I
PARTICULARLY ONBOARDING STAFF
THAT REQUIRE A LOT OF TRAINING-
WHEN WE SAW THAT THAT- THAT.
ACTUATION WAS NOT FOR TO GET
ANY SO. WE NEED TO DO FORWARD
AND SO WE GET- AND SO WE ARE IN
THE PROCESS OF. ARE IN THOSE
POSITIONS- AND HOPE TO HAVE
THOSE BUILT IN THE NEXT FEW
MONTHS- REGARDING THAT THEY
YOU'RE RIGHT FOR MATT- I CAN
SAY IT AT A HIGH LEVEL AND I
MEAN I'LL ET YOU PROVIDER.
OKAY AT ANY DETAILS- NEED AT-
HAVE BEEN GOING. THROUGH A
PROCESS OF TRYING TO A- HOW WE
CAN WE CAN GET BETTER THAT. I
SEVENTEEN. NEXT TO ME SURE THAT
THEY MEET REGULATORY- WE WENT
THROUGH A PROCESS- TO EVALUATE-
HOW ARE OUR- OUR FUNCTIONS ARE
WORKING AND THROUGH THAT
THROUGH THAT EVALUATION WE HAVE
COME OUT THE BACK AND STARTING
TO ISSUE PERMITS AGAIN- WITH A
LOT A HIGHER LEVEL OF SCRUTINY.
I'M TO MAKE SURE THAT WE ARE
ARE. WE ARE ISSUING THOSE
PERMITS AT THE HIGHEST HIGHEST
LEVEL OF INTEGRITY OF THE
REGULATIONS THAT WE HAVE IN
CALIFORNIA. WELL CREATE THE
ANSWER- BUT THE BOTTOM LINE
ITEM FOR ME AND FOR THOSE IN
OUR ARMED AREA OF CALIFORNIA
WHO ARE IN- THE WORK OF ENERGY-
THESE INDIVIDUALS ARE PAYING.
YOUR YOUR YOUR BUDGET. THEY
SHOULD BE ABLE TO EXPECT
REASONABLE AND TIMELY
PERMITTING AS A PROCEDURAL
RIGHT- AND IT APPEARS. THAT
THEY CONTINUE TO PAY HIGHER
FEES. AND CONTINUE TO SEE A
SLOWING. OF THE ACTUAL DUE
PROCESS THAT THEY ARE ENTITLED
TO I DON'T THINK IT'S
PARTICULARLY- NOBLE TO
ESSENTIALLY USE THE
BUREAUCRATIC OPERATION TAKE
FROM THOSE THAT ARE SEEKING THE
PERMIT. AND ESSENTIALLY SAYING
NO. YOU'RE SITTING ON SIXTY YOU
I SEE PERMITS. THAT TO ME A
LOOKS SUSPICIOUSLY LIKE USING
THE OPERATION. TO SAY NO FOUR
WAIT OR MAYBE INSTEAD OF
GETTING TO A YES IT IS TOO SLOW
AND IT IS CAUSING SERIOUS
DAMAGE I THINK TO THE ABILITY
OF CALIFORNIA TO PRODUCE ITS
OWN ENERGY. THANK MISTER. MS
FRIEDMAN AND THEN- ALL RIGHT
MISS REAVIS. THANK YOU DO YOU
HAVE A TARGET DATE ON WHEN YOU
EXPECT THESE POSITIONS TO BE
FILLED THIS YEAR- AND HAS
ISSUED A RECRUITMENT ISSUE AS
FOR YOUR DEPARTMENT OR YOU KNOW
WHY WHY WAS THERE A DELAY WITH
FILLING THESE POSITIONS. I
THINK PROVIDING A TARGET DATE
IS A LITTLE TREACHEROUS- IT
BECAUSE IT DEPENDS ON- HOW THE
ACTUAL INTERVIEW PROCESS GOES
THE EVALUATION OF THE OF THE
APPLICATIONS- AND YOU KNOW
WHETHER SOME OF THOSE POSITIONS
WILL NEED TO BE- REPOSTED- SO.
WHAT I CAN SAY THAT WE'RE DOING
OUR BEST TO PROCESS THOSE
APPLICATIONS AND DO OUR
INTERVIEWS AND SCORING- AS
QUICKLY AS POSSIBLE- AND WE
WILL FILL THOSE POSITIONS- OVER
YOU KNOW OVER THE NEXT NUMBER
OF MONTHS-BUT IT'S HARD TO SAY
EXACTLY WHEN WE WILL BE DONE
FILLING THOSE POSITIONS- IN
TERMS OF RECRUITMENT- WEEK WE
ARE RECEIVING- APPLICATIONS-
AND WE ARE TRYING TO CAST A
WIDE NET TO WHERE WE POST THESE
POSITIONS. AND SO YOU KNOW
RECRUITMENT I THINK IS I
WOULDN'T CALL IT A CHALLENGES
JUST AN ONGOING EFFORT THAT WE
HAVE UNDER WAY TO CONTINUE TO
ADVANCE OUR RECRUITMENT TO TRY
TO REACH TO OTHER COMMUNITIES-
AND TRY TO DIVERSIFY OUR
WORKFORCE- AND SO WE CONTINUE
TO MOVE UP THOSE EFFORTS AS
WELL. I IN THAT PROCESS OF
TRYING TO FILL THESE POSITIONS.
AND THEN POSITIONS GOING
FORWARD. AND I AM ONE MORE
QUESTION FOR YOU GIVE THAT. YOU
WORK IS VERY SPECIALIZED YOU
KNOW OR THESE POSITIONS. OF I
IMAGINE YOU EXPECT TO RETAIN
ONCE YOU HIRE- YOU EXPECT. A
RETURN A GOOD RETENTION RATE OR
IS THERE ANYTHING. OUT THERE
THAT WOULD LEAD YOU NOT TO
EXPECT TO RETAIN. AND YOU KNOW
THESE POSITIONS BECAUSE OF
SOMETHING GOING ON IN THE
INDUSTRY. I THINK THAT'S
CORRECT I WE TEND TO KEEP A
GOOD RETENTION OF OUR
EMPLOYEES- AND CERTAINLY YOU
YOU BRING UP A GOOD POINT THAT-
YOU KNOW THE INDUSTRY I SUPPOSE
THERE'S A COMPETITOR FOR SOME
OF THESE POSITIONS- I'M DONE
THE LETTER STATED THAT THE
PEOPLE THAT WE HIRE ARE MAKING
A COMMITMENT TO. THE STATE
SERVICE- TO IMPLEMENTING THE
REGULATIONS PROMULGATED BY THE
LEGISLATURE- AND- THAT YOU KNOW
THAT THE MISSION OF CAL JAM-
THAT THEY'RE MAKING THAT
COMMITMENT AND THEY THEY THEY
DO TEND TO STAY ON BOARD FOR A
LONG. TIME THANK YOU. MS
FRIEDMAN THANK YOU- I WOULD.
WHO'S GOING TO JUST ASK A
COUPLE QUESTIONS ONE HAVING TO
DO WITH MR PATTERSON'S QUESTION
I'M SORRY THAT HE ASKED A LOT
OF QUESTIONS AND WANT TO STICK
AROUND TO HEAR THE DISCUSSION.
BUT HE MENTIONED THAT- THESE
OPERATORS ARE PAYING FOR
PERMITS AND THAT YOU'RE TAKING
A LONG TIME TO GET TO A YES ARE
THEY ALWAYS GUARANTEED TO GET A
YES FOR EVERY SINGLE PERMIT
THAT THEY APPLIED FOR IS THAT
IS THAT THE GUARANTEE THEY PAY
THIS MONEY YOU DO THE REVIEW
AND THEY ALWAYS GET THEIR
PERMIT. IF THE REVIEW FINDS
FALLS. IN IN THEIR- APPLICATION
THEN THEY DO NOT GET A PERMIT-
SO I WOULD SAY THAT IF THEY DO
CONTINUE TO COME BACK WITH IT.
THAT'S CORRECT THE INFORMATION
THAT WE NEED TO PROCESS THE
PERMIT. EVENTUALLY THEY MAY GET
THE PERMIT. BUT IT'S NOT
GUARANTEED IF THEY CANNOT.
PROVIDE ALL THE INFORMATION
NEEDED TO TAKE ISSUE THE FROM
THAT. SO HIS HIS ARGUMENT THAT.
SOME OF THESE OPERATORS ARE
IMMEDIATELY GETTING A YES-
DOESN'T REALLY. SOUND LIKE
THAT'S EXACTLY WHAT'S SUPPOSED
TO HAPPEN RIGHT THEY'RE PAYING
YOU TO DO A RIGOROUS. REVIEW OF
THEIR PERMIT. AND THEN IF
THERE. IS CORRECT IN THE
ENVIRONMENTAL DOCUMENTS. AND
IT. CAN BE A- APPROVED UNDER
REGULATORY GUIDELINES THEN THEY
CAN GET A PERMIT BUT THEY'RE
NOT GUARANTEED TO ALWAYS GET A
PERMIT CORRECT. THAT'S CORRECT-
THAT'S GREAT THANK YOU- SO I
WANTED TO SWITCH TO ASK ABOUT
AB TEN FIFTY SEVEN FROM TWO
THOUSAND NINETEEN- WHICH IS
ALSO UNDER. YOUR JURISDICTION
HOW MANY OPERATOR RISK
EVALUATIONS THAT THAT BILL
REQUIRED HAVE BEEN COMPLETED AT
THIS POINT. ASSEMBLY MEMBER
I'LL OUT SUPERVISOR INSTRUCTED
TO ANSWER. GOOD MORNING
ASSEMBLY WOMAN- WE CURRENTLY
HAVE NOT COMPLETED THE- AND
EVALUATION YET THESE ARE THE
POSITIONS WERE HIRING- THE
TWENTY ONE TO THIS IS THAT OUR-
NEAR COMPLETE- WE ALSO- HAVE
BEGUN- EVALUATION OF CALIFORNIA
RESOURCE CORPORATION IS THE%
FIRST. ENTITY TO GO THROUGH THE
PROCESS BUT THIS IS A VERY A
COMPLEX AND- HELLO PROCESS GO
THROUGH THE EVALUATION THAT.
BUT WE HAVE NOT COMPLETED ONE
YET. THE BILL ALSO ALLOWED FOR
ADDITIONAL SECURITY OF UP TO
THIRTY MILLION DOLLARS- A TO B.
THIS TO BE- PUT UP BY THE
OPERATORS ARE HOW MANY OF THE
OPERATORS HAVE. HAVE SECURED
THAT THREE MILLION DOLLARS. WE
CURRENTLY DON'T HAVE ANY
OPERATORS OF SECURED THIRTY
MILLION DOLLARS AND BONDING. SB
SEVEN TWENTY FOUR IN TWO
THOUSAND SEVENTEEN GAVE THE
DIVISION THREE MILLION DOLLARS
A YEAR TO PLUG AND ABANDON
ORPHAN WELLS FOR THREE YEARS.
HAVE HAS A DIVISION BEEN ABLE
TO UTILIZE THE FULL AMOUNT EACH
YEAR AND I'M WONDERING WHAT THE
BARRIERS ARE TO IDENTIFYING
MORE AND MORE OF THESE
ABANDONED WELLS AND PLUGGING
THEM UP FOR THE SAFETY OF THE
COMMUNITY IN OUR ENVIRONMENT.
HOW MANY ARE YOU DOING AND
OTHER BARRIERS TO DOING MORE OF
THEM. YEAH I CAN DO THAT
QUESTIONS OF WOMAN- WE
CURRENTLY SPEND UP TO THE THREE
MILLION DOLLAR THRESHOLD IN THE
LAST FEW YEARS I WILL HAVE TO
FOLLOW UP TO GET THE EXACT
NUMBER WAS OF AN ABANDONED BUT
I KNOW THE CHALLENGES HAS BEEN-
THERE'S A RIGOROUS PROCESS TO
CLEAR- WELL ORPHAN- TO ALLOW US
TO USE IT. ARE YOU DO YOU STATE
FUNDING. THERE ALSO ARE OTHER
LIMITATIONS SOMETIMES ON ACCESS
TO SITES THAT- THAT MAKE IT
CHALLENGING I KNOW- THERE'S A
SIDE NORTH L. A. COUNTY THAT
WE'VE NOT BEEN ABLE TO GET YOU
BECAUSE THERE'S NO ACCESS ROAD
AND WE'RE TRYING TO WORK WITH
THE LOCAL MUNICIPALITY IT TO
REDO THE ROAD BECAUSE WE CAN'T
GET A BREAK THEIR TO. ABANDON
THE WELLS- SO THERE'S THOSE
TYPE OF CHALLENGES BUT WILL
HAVE TO GO BACK ON THE SPECIFIC
VERSE. OKAY SO HAVE YOU BEEN
USING THE FULL AMOUNT OF THE%
THREE MILLION DOLLARS. A YEAR
OR IS SOME OF THAT MONEY BEING
PUT ASIDE FOR COMPLETION. OF
THE FUTURE OF THESE X. I
BELIEVE. YEAR WE DID SPEND THE
THREE MILLION DOLLARS. IN THE
LAST FISCAL YEAR- AND IT DOES
ACCUMULATE THERE IN THE IN THE
FUND- I BELIEVE WE'RE AT
APPROXIMATELY THIRTEEN MILLION
DOLLARS IN THE HIT WAFFEN BUT
YOU ANTICIPATE BEING ABLE TO
THAT WHEN YOU STAFF UP AND- ARE
YOU ANTICIPATING BEING ABLE TO
SORT OF USE MORE OF THAT MONEY
MORE QUICKLY NOW AND- COULD.
THE PROCESS. OF THIS IMPORTANT
WORK. WHAT DO YOU EXPECTMONEY
THAT IS CIRCULATING. NO WE DO
WE A ANTICIPATE SPENDING THAT
MONEY- THAT'S A FOCUS OF OURS
IS ACTUALLY WAS ONE OF THE
ITEMS IN THAT THE GOVERNOR'S
EXECUTIVE ORDER THIS LAST
SEPTEMBER. WE WANT TO
ACCELERATE AN ABANDONED MOR
WELLS. OKAY LET'S MOVE OUT TO
THE UNDER TO UNDERGROUND
INJECTION CONTROLS- HELLO
YOU'VE IMPROVE REGULATIONS IN
RECENT YEARS- TO BETTER.
REGULATE THIS TYPE OF ACTIVITY
AND STIMULATION ACTIVITY. BUT
EXISTING PROJECTS DON'T HAVE TO
OPERATE UNDER THOSE STRONGER
REGULATIONS IT'S ONLY WHEN THEY
UNDERGO THEIR ANNUAL REVIEW
THAT'S MY UNDERSTANDING. SO I'M
WONDERING HOW MANY AT THE U. I
SEE PROJECTS HAVE ALREADY HAD
THAT IN YOUR REVIEW AND HOW
QUICKLY YOU'D EXPECT TO START
CYCLING THROUGH THOSE PROJECTS
TO ENACT THE STRONGER
REGULATIONS. I MEAN A WEEK
DOZENS OF YEARS AWAY AFTER
YEARS AWAY WHEN DID THEY START
GETTING KIND OF LOSING THEIR-
GRANDFATHER DENNIS FOR THE
WEAKER REGULATIONS AND START
TRANSITIONING. YES IT NEW YOU I
SEE REGULATIONS WHEN DEFECTIVE
APRIL TWENTY NINETEEN- AND ARE
EFFECTIVE FOR ALL PROJECTS
GOING FORWARD SO NEW PROJECTS
MUST MEET THE NEW REQUIREMENTS-
AND THEN. THEY WERE DOING
MANUAL PROJECT BY PROJECT
REVIEW- TO MAKE IT TO MAKE
SURE- THAT THEY APPLIED SOME OF
THESE. OLDER PROJECTS FROM SAY
THE NINETEEN EIGHTIES OR
NINETEEN NINETIES ARE VERY
LITTLE INFORMATION. AND TAKE-
QUITE A BIT OF TIME TO GET IN
GET IT UP TO THE CURRENT
STANDARD SO- WE'RE WORKING
THROUGH THAT I KNOW IN OUR
PROJECT BY PROJECT REVIEW- THIS
PAST YEAR WE COMPLETED EIGHTY.
AS FAR AS BUT THERE ARE SEVERAL-
SORRY EIGHTY REVIEWS OF ALL
PROJECTS OR THE ABUSE NEW
OPERATIONS CORRECT. OKAY ALL
PROJECTS- BUT THERE ARE SEVERAL
HUNDRED AYE AYE I WANT TO IN
THE BALLPARK- OF. ABOUT NINE
HUNDRED- PROJECTS- SO IT YOU
KNOW IT IT IT IT IT JUST
ESTIMATING AT THE CURRENT PACE
YES WOULD BE SEVERAL YEARS. TO
GET THROUGH TO OF ALL THE
PROJECTS. THESE NEW POSITIONS-
PART OF THE RESPONSIBILITY WILL
BE ADDED- THESE DISHES FEEL
PRESENCE WILL HELP WITH YOU I
SEE PERMITTING REVIEWS- PLUS
THE NEW POSITIONS WERE ALSO
HIRING FOR RIGHT NOW. WE DID.
GO AHEAD SORRY. WE WILL LITTLE
LACK I WAS A WEE. NO PROBLEM-
WE DID AS WORKLOAD NOW TO YEARS
AGO. IT THE ORIGINAL ONE
HUNDRED TWENTY EIGHT POSITIONS-
WAS BECAUSE OF THE SUBSTANTIAL
DEFICIT WE HAD AND WHAT WE ARE
REQUIRED TO DO. AND OUR
STAFFING AND SEWER. WILL
CONTINUE TO MAKE PROGRESS WITH
THE STAFF WE HAVE AND IN THIS
IS WHY WE'RE COMING BACK FOR.
ADDITIONAL STAFF POSITIONS SO
THOSE EIGHTY PROJECTS THAT YOU
REVIEWED OUT OF THE NINE
HUNDRED PLUS NOW THOSE ONES ARE
THOSE PROJECTS ARE SORT OF
MOVED UP INTO THAT HIGHER LEVEL
OF REVIEW AND REGULATION. SO
THEY WERE. THE TERM RATED
THEY'VE THEY'VE V. FOR THE
CORRECT STAND ONE OF. APRIL OF
TWENTY NINE. AND THEN MY LAST
QUESTION- IS ABOUT CYCLIC STEAM
INJECTION SO AFTER THE CIMAREX.
OIL SPILL- WE HAVE- YOU'RE
REVIEWING SOME OF THE CYCLIC
STEAM PROJECTS TO JUST MAKE
SURETHAT WE DON'T HAVE A
REPEAT OF THAT OIL SPILL. HOW
IS MY IS THAT'S MY
UNDERSTANDING AND I'M WONDERING
HOW MANY OF THOSE REVIEWS OF
CURRENT CYCLIC STEAMING. UP
PROJECTS HAVE YOU BEEN ABLE TO
UNDERGO HOW MANY OF YOU TAKE A
LOOK AT. WE CURRENTLY HAVE A
MORATORIUM ON HIGH PRESSURE
CYCLIC STEAMING. THAT WAS THE
TYPE OF OPERATION THAT WAS
OCCURRING IN SOME REC FOR
NUMBER NEW NEW OPERATIONS RIGHT
WHAT ABOUT I'M ASKING ABOUT
REVIEWING- ONGOING OPERATIONS
ARE YOU DOING REVIEWS OF ANY OF
THOSE. SO WE'RE WE'RE WORKING
ON LARGELY MORE NATIONAL LAB ON
REVIEWING. CURRENT OPERATIONS-
THERE'S- FORTHCOMING REPORT
THAT- WILL ASSESS THAT AND THAT
THAT REVIEWED ALL ALL
OPERATIONS IN STATE. AS I
REVIEW A SORT OF A HYPOTHETICAL
REVIEW OR IS THAT ACTUALLY
LOOKING AT SPECIFIC- WELLS.
IT'S LOOKING AT SPECIFIC-
OPERATORS WELLS GEOLOGY- OF
CURRENT OPERATIONS IN THE STATE
IS NOT A THEORETICAL RIGHT SO
IT'LL COME OUT AND REVIEW THE
RISK FOR ALL OF THE CURRENT-
WELLS THAT ARE USING CYCLIC
STEAMING. SEVEN KIND CORRECT
OKAY THANK YOU YEAH WE MET
WITH- OKAY I APPRECIATE YOUR-
QUESTION A QUICK FOLLOW UP ON
THAT WHEN DO YOU ANTICIPATE
THAT REPORT WILL BE. FINALIZED
I WILL WE HOPE IN THE NEXT
THIRTY DAYS WE DO HAVE A FINAL
DRAFT THAT WE- ARE- REVIEWING.
GREAT I LOOK FORWARD TO HAVING
A LOOK AT THAT MR BENNETT HAS A
QUESTION THANK YOU VERY MUCH OF
THE MOST RECENT REPORT- FROM
CAL JOBS ON IDLE WELLS IS YOUR
TWENTY EIGHTEEN I DON'T WELL
REPORT. IN WHICH IT INDICATES
THAT THERE ARE NINE HUNDRED
FIFTY TWO OPERATORS OF THAT
HAVE NOT PAID TO WRITE A WELL
FEES ON TWO THOUSAND TWO
HUNDRED AND FIFTY TWO WELLS- MY
QUESTION IS NOW TODAY DO WE
KNOW. HOW MANY OF THOSE FROM
TWENTY EIGHTEEN OF ACTUALLY
PAID WHAT THE NUMBER IS OF. I
DON'T WELL OPERATORS THAT- ARE
STILL. OF NEGLIGENT IN TERMS OF
PAYING THEIR FEES AND HOW MANY
WELLS ARE ARE A COVERED BY THE.
WE DO KNOW THE ANSWER BUT I
DON'T HAVE IT AT HIM- THIS
MORNING- WE CAN FOLLOW UP AND
PROVIDE THAT TO YOU. SO YOU CAN
PROVIDE THAT THANK YOU- MY NEXT
QUESTION IS. DO YOU NEED NEW
AUTHORITY OR NEW TOOLS TO BE
ABLE TO COLLECT THESE I DON'T
WELL FEES TO HAVE THAT KIND OF
BACKLOG NINE HUNDRED FIFTY TWO
OPERATORS NOT PAYING THEIR
FEES. TWO THOUSAND TWO HUNDRED
FIFTY TWO IDLE WELLS NOT THAT
COVERED. OF SINCE THAT'S THE
MOST RECENT INFORMATION TWENTY
EIGHTEEN. DO YOU NEED MORE
TOOLS MORE AUTHORITY. WELL WE
CURRENTLY ONLY HAVE
ADMINISTRATIVE- ENFORCEMENT
AUTHORITY WE WORK WITH THE
STATE COMPTROLLER'S OFFICE ON-
UNPAID. FEES AND ASSESSMENTS-
WE DON'T HAVE A YOU KNOW
CRIMINAL AUTHORITY OR CIVIL
AUTHORITY THAT THEY WOULD- YOU
MIGHT. ASSIST WITH THE
COLLECTIONS. THANK YOU- AND
THEN WHEN WHILE THE TWENTY
NINETEEN I DON'T WILL REPORT
COME OUT WHEN WILL THE TWENTY
TWENTY I DON'T WELL REPORTS
COME OUT. FOR THEIR PENDING
THAT REVIEW WE HOPE TO HAVE
THEM OUT SHORTLY. DISKIN CAN
SHORTLY CAN YOU GIVE ME A ROUGH
BALLPARK IS THAT MONTHS IS THAT.
A YEAR- I MEAN TWENTY NINETEEN
REPORT IT'S WE'RE TWENTY TWENTY
ONE HERE NOW. HI I HOPE IN THE
NEXT FEW WEEKS. THANK YOU.
MISTER SMITH THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR WELL IN REGARDS TO THE
QUESTION IS IN REGARDS TO THE
ANNUAL REPORT WE'RE STILL
WAITING FOR TWENTY NINETEEN YOU
SAY BY COME OUT THE NEXT COUPLE
WEEKS WHEN CAN WE ANTICIPATE
TWENTY TWENTIES REPORT COMING
OUT- BECAUSE THERE WERE ALREADY
A YEAR LAGGING. IS IT GOING TO
BE ANOTHER YEAR BEFORE WE GET
TO TWENTY TWENTY REPORT. FOR
THE TWENTY TWENTY REPORT IS DUE
OUT THIS SUMMER- MY GOAL IS TO
HIT THAT DEADLINE. THANK YOU
WILK BOOK WILL PUT YOU ON THE
TIME CLOCK ALREADY THEN THANK
YOU VERY MUCH FOR THAT BUT BY
OTHER QUESTIONS ARE IN REGARDS
TO THE- PUBLIC RESOURCE CARD
THIRTY ONE OH SIX. AND IT
STATES TO BEST. MEET THE OIL
AND GAS NEEDS IN THIS STATE. OF
SUPERVISORS SHALL ADMINISTER
THIS DIVISION. AS TO ENCOURAGE
THE WISE DEVELOPMENT OF OIL AND
GAS RESOURCES. CURRENTLY 70%
BETWEEN SIXTY FIVE AND 70% OF
CALIFORNIA OR LEADS OR BEING
IMPORTED. FROM FOREIGN
COUNTRIES THAT DO NOT HAVE THE
CALIFORNIA VALUES. CALIFORNIA
VITAMIN A FOR PROTECTION
POLICIES. CALIFORNIA'S
COMMUNITARIAN VALUES AND WE'RE
RECEIVING NO TAXES IN THE
CALIFORNIA SO I WOULD LIKE TO
SEE IS BEING ABLE TO DRILL MORE
GET THE PERMITS OUT QUICKER SO
WE DO NOT SUPPORT FOREIGN
COUNTRIES. BECAUSE WE'RE NOT
USING ANY LESS OIL. WE'RE
IMPORTING MORE OIL INTO
CALIFORNIA. ANY RESPONSE OR
JUST MY COMMENTS. I'M NOT SURE
YOU POSE THE QUESTION SO OR IS
THERE A QUESTION THAT YOU'RE
ASKING YEAH- THAT. YOU'D LIKE
THEM TO RESPOND POWERS I WAS
CAL JIMMY COURAGEIN THE
DEVELOPMENT OF OIL AND GAS TO
MEET CALIFORNIA'S ENERGY NEEDS.
IT'S GOING TO GET OUT SURE I
CAN TAKE A CRACK AT THAT- SO
CAL JIM REVIEWS- PERMIT
APPLICATIONS THAT COME IN- YEAH
M. AND PROCESS THEM AND WE HAVE
A GEO TECHNICAL STAFF
THROUGHOUT THE STATE- WE
CONTINUE TO FOLLOW THE LAW AND-
REVIEW AND AN ISSUE OR DENY
PERMITS. AS THEY COME THROUGH
AND DO INSPECTIONS AND
OVERSIGHT- BUT WE ARE
RESPONSIVE IS WHAT APPLICATIONS
COME IN WHICH MANY TIMES
CORRELATE WITH THE PRICE OF
OIL- THAT WE HAVE NO CONTROL
OVER AND SO. AS APPLICATIONS
COME IN WE REVIEW THEM. AND GO
THROUGH THE REGULATORY PROCESS.
MISTER BENNETT. THANK YOU COULD
YOU- SINCE I'M NEW HERE COULD
YOU JUST IDENTIFY FOR ME WHY
THE TWENTY NINETEEN REPORT HAS
MISSED ITS DEADLINE IN THIS
SHOW FOR SO LATE. IT IS
CURRENTLY UNDER REVIEW- WE'VE
BEEN SELLING STRATEGIC
POSITIONS IT WOULD MAKE IT FOR
SOMETIMES UP TO TWO YEARS- AND
WE'RE WORKING DILIGENTLY TO- IT
IS OUR REPORTS OUT THIS QUICK
AS WE CAN. SO BASICALLY IF YOU
DIDN'T HAVE YOU DIDN'T HAVE
SOMEBODY IN A POSITION TO DO
THIS THIS TWENTY THAT THERE WAS
NOTHING ELSE THAT CAP TO TWENTY
NINETEEN REPORT. EXCEPT THE
LACK OF MANPOWER. THAT WAS A
CONTRIBUTING FACTOR YES. WAS
THERE SOMETHING ELSE BESIDES A
LACK OF MANPOWER THAT BECAUSE
TO TWENTY NINETEEN I TO WILL
REPORT TO BE SOLELY. NO THANK
YOU. ALL RIGHT- LOOKS LIKE
WE'VE EXHAUSTED QUESTIONS ON-
ON- THESE THREE ITEMS- I DON'T
BELIEVE WE HEARD FROM ALEJO OR
OR- DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE. THE
MORNING CARE THIS IS- UNITS
WROTE THE L. A. OUT CAN WE
OFFER SOME COMMENTS ON ISSUE
NUMBER SEVEN. YES PLEASE. RIGHT
AT SO YEAH WE FIND THE
RESOURCES REQUEST AN
ADMINISTRATION PROPOSAL ARE
REASONABLE BASED ON EXISTING
BACKLOG AT FIELD INSPECTION.
GAP BETWEEN IMPORTANT ACTION IN
CAPACITY AND VOLUME OF
INFORMATION AND DATA REQUESTS
FROM THE PUBLIC- AND IN
ADDITION I HAVE MANY MEMBERS-
NOTED RECENT LEGISLATION HAS
INCREASED. OVERSIGHT
REQUIREMENTS WHICH HAS
INCREASED THE DIVISION'S WORK A
LOT BUT AND- FURTHER THAT
DIVISION AKHLAQ- HOWEVER- AS
THAT THE PROVIDER NOTED CONTENT
ANNUAL AND FIELD IN OFFICE OVER
IT WORKLOAD IF SOME MIGHT
ANSWER AND- AND CAN BE CHANGED
OVER TIME FOR A NUMBER OF
REASONS AND- ON THE FACTORS
THAT. WE'LL LOOK- WE'RE
DISCUSSING WHERE. THE MARKET
FACTORS- BUT ALSO THE GEOGRAPHY
OF PRODUCTION THE COMPLEXITY OF
REVIEWS AND ATTICUS DANCER IN
HERE REAL RELATED TO
IMPLEMENTING NEW PROGRAMS AND
RELATED TO THAT RECENT
LEGISLATION THAT AND- HI SO WE
RECOMMEND THE LEGISLATURE
APPROVED A BUDGET REQUEST TO
MEET THE INCREASED WORKLOAD
ASSOCIATED WITH THE REGULATORY
CHANGE AND- WE FIND THAT THESE
RESOURCES ARE JUSTIFIED AND I
WORK WOULD BE SAID AND ARE
CONSISTENT WITH RECENT
STATUTORY REQUIREMENTS. HOWEVER
SINCE THE AMOUNT OF FUEL THAT
OVERSIGHT WORKLOAD COULD VARY
DEPENDING ON SEVERAL FACTORS-
pTHE SUPPLEMENTAL REPORTING
LANGUAGE THAT REQUIRES THE
DEPARTMENT TO PROVIDE AN UPDATE
ON THE DIVISION'S PERFORMANCE
IN SEVERAL AREAS THAT
OPERATIONS BY- AND JANUARY
FIRST TWENTY TWENTY FIVE AFTER.
THE FULL IMPLEMENTATION OF THIS
PROPOSAL. THANK YOU. DEPARTMENT
OF. YES THIS IS MOLLY MCGUIRE
WITH DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE-
JUST- IN RESPONSE TO THE L. A.
O. SCOTT MANTZ- YOU. KNOW WE'RE
WE'RE- COMMITTEE. IT WELL WE'RE
HAVING A HARD. ALL RIGHT TIME
HEARING YOUR COMMENTS INTO HIS-
OF THE DATA. A THE COUCH I'M
PRODUCES AND- ALISA SYNTHESIZED.
YUP UNFORTUNATELY WE HAVEN'T
BEEN ABLE TO REALLY MAKE OUT
YOUR COMMENTS- I DON'T KNOW IF
THERE'S ANY ANY ME HERE MEAN
NOW. IS A LITTLE BIT BROKEN BUT
YOU COULD TRY AGAIN. LITTLE
CHOPPY. CAN YOU HEAR ME NOW WE
CAN HEAR YOU I DON'T THINK THE
PROBLEM WAS- MUTING IT AT- WAS-
YOUR CONNECTION I BELIEVE. C. I
SHOULD HAVE ANOTHER TRY. CAN
YOU TAKE IT FROM THE TOP. OKAY
CAN YOU HEAR ME NOW. I THINK SO
LET'S GIVE IT A TRY ARE YOU ARE
YOU ABLE TO HEAR ME. L. I'M NOT
SURE YOU CAN HEAR ME. CAN YOU
HEAR ME. IT'S NOT GOOD WHEN
PEOPLE DON'T LISTEN TO THE
CHAIR. OKAY ALL RIGHT HERE ARE
JUST A LET ME LET ME START OVER
SO- HI IN RESPONSE. IN RESPONSE.
THIS CONNECTION IS REALLY BAD
AND SINCE WE'RE JUST IN
RESPONSE TO THE L. A. L.'S
COMMENTS- YOU KNOW THE
DEPARTMENT OF. FIND. I THINK
WHAT WE SHOULD ASK IS THAT YOU
ARE PROVIDE YOUR COMMENTS TO US
IN WRITING I CAN'T AT WE'RE NOT
TAKING TODAY ANYWAY IN HERE YOU.
YOU CAN HEAR ME OUT I THINK
MIGHT HAVE BEEN A MY QUESTION
FROM A COUPLE OF MINUTES AGO.
CAN YOU HEAR ME YEAH YEAH OKAY
I CAN HEAR YOU ALL RIGHT. LET'S
GIVE IT ONE MORE TRY. I CAN
ASSURE YOU I'M WILL BE NEAR YOU.
YEAH I THINK WE HAVE A LEAD
GOING ON HER BREAK A COUPLE OF
MINUTES LACK. THANK. WE GOT UP
ON THE SCREEN NOW RESEARCH
RESEARCHERS EVEN BANDS WITH THE
PROBLEM I THINK THE BIG. THIS
IS STEVEN BENSON DEPARTMENT
FINANCE HELLO CAN YOU HEAR ME
MY COLLEAGUES. WE HAVE A COVERT
HERE A PROBLEM. SO I'M I ACT I
THINK RATHER THAN. FURTHER TIME
RIGHT NOW I'M GOING TO ASK IF
WE COULD MUTE TO OTHER
MICROPHONES BECAUSE THERE'S
CLEARLY A LACK IN THE
RESPONDENT YOU KNOW COMMENTS
THAT I MADE A COUPLE OF MINUTES
AGO- AND WILL LAST DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE TO- SUBMIT SOMETHING
IN WRITING GUY IF THERE ARE
COMMENTS IN RESPONSE TO THIS
ITEM. SO THAT WE HAVE THEM IN
ADVANCE OF WHEN THIS ISSUE
COMES BACK. IF THERE'S NO
OBJECTION TO THAT TO I THINK
THAT'S PROBABLY THE BEST WAY TO
HANDLE THIS PARTICULAR
SITUATION. AND MERCIFULLY
BRINGS US- TO THE END OF THE-
THE HEARING WILL MOVE ON TO NOT
THAT- OF THE ENTIRE HEARING
WILL MOVE ON TO PUBLIC COMMENT
NOW- LET ME BEGIN BY ASKING IF
THERE ARE ANY. MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC IN THE ROOM ONE AT A
TIME- IF YOU COULD COME UP TO
THE MICROPHONE AND AVOID
TOUCHING THE MICROPHONE. OF
THAT'LL BE GREATLY APPRECIATED
AND- YOU'LL EACH HAVE ONE
MINUTE I SEE TWO PEOPLE ARE
WAITING. THANK YOU TURN MEMBERS
OF MY NAME'S JERRY DOES MEN ON
BEHALF A RECREATIONAL BOATERS
OF CALIFORNIA- COMMENTING ON
THE BOATING FUND DEFICIENCY
PROPOSAL BY THE GOVERNOR WE
HAVE A COUPLE OF SPEAKERS WILL
SPEAK AFTER MEAL TOUCH UPON.
OUR COMMUNITY FOURTEEN
DIFFERENT ORGANIZATIONS HAVE
COME TOGETHER IN COMMENTS IN A
LETTER WE HAVE SUBMITTED TO THE
COMMITTEE. TO CONSIDER TO MAKE
THIS PROPOSAL REASONABLE AND
FAIR THE MAIN ISSUES THAT WE
ADDRESS OUR WHEN WE TALK ABOUT
THE TWO HUNDRED FIFTY DOLLARS A
PERCENT INCREASE THAT'S MUCH
LARGER THAN ACOSTA LEVY
INCREASE. AND THE EXPLANATION
THAT IS GIVEN IS THAT THAT THE
STAFF INCREASES ARE FOR PROGRAM
SAID BARELY IF AT ALL BENEFIT
BORDERS PRIMARILY SO. THE BEACH
EROSION PROGRAM WAS EMPHASIZED
AS A REASON FOR THE CALL FOR
THE STAFF INCREASED THE
INVASIVE SPECIES PROGRAM THAT
HAS GROWN EXPONENTIALLY AND-
BENEFITS MUCH MORE THAN JUST
VOTERS AUTHOR ON THE WATERWAYS
AND ON OUR WATERWAYS SECOND IS.
THE CONTEXT THE FREE INCREASE
IS LOOKED AT AS JUST A FREE
INCREASE AND IT IGNORES THAT
THERE ARE A HUNDRED AND SEVEN
MILLION DOLLARS AND VOTER FUEL
TAX DOLLARS. MUCH MORE WHICH
USED TO BE DEPOSITED THERE WILL
POPPING FUN INSTEAD. IT'S BEING
DIRECTED OVER TO STATE PARKS
FOR DIFFERENT PEOPLE STATE
PARKS OF PROGRAMS AND SERVICES
SOME OF WHICH HAVE TENDED TO
SOMEBODY TO BOATERS. SO ONLY
14% OF OUR FUEL TAX DOLLARS WE
PAID AT THE STATE. PARK WITH
GOING TO THE H. W. R. F. IN
ADDITION VOTERS PAY SIGNIFICANT
PROPERTY TAXES AT THE. LOCAL
LEVEL WITH SOME TRIGGERS THEIR-
OKAY. YOUR COMMENTS PLEASE THE.
COURTESY OPPORTUNITIES TO TALK.
AND WE HAVE SOLUTIONS IN OUR
LETTER TO THAT OUR SPEAKERS
WILL ADDRESS. THANK YOU THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. MISTER CHAIR
MEMBERS MARK SMITH ON BEHALF OF
THE NATIONAL MARINE
MANUFACTURERS ASSOCIATION ALL
LINE MY COMMENTS WITH THOSE OF
THE SPEAKERBEFORE ME BUT LIKE
TO TALK ABOUT THE PROCESS WE'VE
KNOWN. ABOUT THIS ISSUE WITH
THE FUND FOR YEARS OUR
ORGANIZATION SENT A LETTER TO
THE DEPARTMENT AND THE DIVISION
OF BOATING AND WATERWAYS IN MAY
OF TWENTY TWENTY. WE RECEIVED A
RESPONSE TO THAT LETTER AT TEN
O'CLOCK THE NIGHT BEFORE THE
SENATE HEARD THIS ITEM OVER ON
THEIR SIDE. IT DOESN'T GIVE US
A LOT OF TIME FOR DIALOGUE
WE'VE ASKED INSISTENTLY TO BE A
PART OF ANY SOLUTION THAT WOULD
BE PUT FORWARD. AND TO PUT A
210050% FEE INCREASE ON US.
WITHOUT RESOLVING SOME OF THESE
OTHER ISSUES WHAT IS THE FUND
APPROPRIATELY BEING USED FOR
OUR WE THE SOUL- BENEFITS ARE
WE THE SOLE FUNDERS OF THINGS
LIKE THAT- IT JUST IT DOESN'T
LEAVE. A GOOD TASTE IN OUR
MOUTHS A STAKEHOLDERS IN TERMS
OF BEING LISTENED TO AND BEING
ENGAGED IN THIS PROCESS. YOU
ASKED FOR OUR COMMENTS MISTER
CHAIR ON WHAT THE L. A. O. SAID
WHAT OTHER SAID ON THE SIDE AND
THEIR SOLUTION CONTINUES TO BE
RAISING THE FEES EVEN HIGHER
AND REDUCING THE SERVICES EVEN
MORE. THAT'S NOT AN ACCEPTABLE
OUTCOME TO US IN THE SITUATION
I DO THINK WE NEED TO LOOK AT
THE MONIES THAT ARE BEING
REDIRECTED TO DEPARTMENT OF
PARKS- AS THE PREVIOUS SPEAKER
NOTED WE ONLY GET 40% OF OUR
FUEL TAXES THAT WE PAY INTO THE
STATE. THANK YOU WE LOOK
FORWARD TO AN ONGOING DIALOGUE.
THANK YOU. ALL RIGHT SO WE'LL
MOVE TO- THE PHONE LINES NOW
THERE APPEARS TO BE NO ONE ELSE
LEFT IN THE ROOM WHO WISHES TO
SPEAK AT- LET ME REPEAT THE
PHONE NUMBER FOR ANYBODY WHO.
MAY BE. LISTENING AND JUST
WANTED TO CALL AND- WE'LL GET
TO THOSE WHO ARE ALREADY ON THE
LINE IN JUST A MOMENT. THE TOLL
FREE NUMBER IS EIGHT SEVEN
SEVEN SIX NINE TWO EIGHT NINE.
1-287-769-2895 SEVEN. AND THE
CODE. PUBLIC ACCESS CODE IS.
1-315-437-1315 FOUR. THREE
SEVEN IF YOU HAVE A PROBLEM-
LOG IN HONOR- GETTING ACCESS
PLEASE CONTACT THE ASSEMBLY
BUDGET COMMITTEE OFFICE AT NINE
ONE SIX. THREE ONE NINE. TWO
ZERO NINE NINE A STAFF MEMBER
WILL ASSIST YOU. AGAIN THAT'S.
916-319-2099 OPERATOR YOU READY
TO ROCK AND ROLL HERE. YEAH
pLIKE TO MAKE A COMMENT PRESS
THE ONE ZERO AT THIS TIME. WE
WILL BEGIN WITH ALIGNMENT
TWENTY THREE. MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS SHAUN WALL IN TIME FROM
THE CALIFORNIA INDEPENDENT
PETROLEUM ASSOCIATION WE
REPRESENT ALMOST ONE HUNDRED
OIL AND NATURAL GAS PRODUCERS
IN CALIFORNIA WHICH FUND 1100%
OF CHALDEANS REGULATORY BUDGET-
WE HAVE CONCERNS ABOUT THE
BUDGET AUGMENTATIONS FOR
CALTRANS ON ISSUE SIX. WE ARE
NOT SUPPORTIVE- AT THIS TIME OF
CONVERTING THOSE TWENTY ONE
LIMITED TERM POSITIONS TO
PERMANENT POSITIONS IF YOU DO
RE AUTHORIZED THESE POSITIONS
WE REQUESTED TO KEEP THEM
LIMITED TERM AGREE THAT THAT
THEIR PERFORMANCE WHEN THEY
SUNSET THREE YEARS FROM NOW. ON
ISSUE SEVEN WE OPPOSE THIS- CAL
GEM AS YOU'VE HEARD DURING THIS
HEARING I RECEIVED TWENTY ONE
TWENTY FIVE NEW POSITIONS LAST
LAST YEAR'S BUDGET THEY HIRED
FOR. WE HAVE SERIOUS DOUBTS AT
THEIR RATE OF ONBOARDING THAT
THEY WILL GET THE ENTIRE BEFORE
THE END OF THIS FISCAL YEAR I'D
LIKE TO KNOW TO THE CAL JIM HAS
HAD A CHRONIC VACANCY RATE OVER
THE LAST SIX BUDGET CYCLE OF
ABOUT 17% CURRENTLY CAL CHEN
HAS ABOUT SIXTY VACANCIES.
WHICH IS OVER 18% AS BY WAY OF
A VACANCY RATE THEY DO NOT NEED
MORE STAFF AT THIS TIME- WHEN
THEY ARE OPERATIONALLY
DEFICIENT AT 20% THE RETENTION
AS IT WAS BROUGHT UP BY A
MEMBER EARLIER IS NOT GOOD.
ALSO CONCERNING TO US IS THE
CALCIUM HAS LOANED OUT THIRTEEN
FULL TIME STAFF POSITIONS YOU
CODED CONTACT TRACING FOR THE
PAST SEVERAL MONTHS AT A COST
TO OUR OIL PRODUCERS OF OVER
HALF A MILLION DOLLARS THIS IS
LEGALLY QUESTIONABLE SINCE IT
HAD NOTHING TO DO WITH THE OIL
AND GAS OVERSIGHT. WHICH ARE
SPECIAL FEES PAID ON PER BARREL
LEVIED ON OUR MEMBERS AND I'D
LIKE TO BE CLEAR SHARE MEMBERS
THAT CAN I HAVE YOUR ORDER. IF
I PLACE THE DEPARTMENTS. YES
YES SEVEN SUPPORT- CAL CHEN
STAFF INCREASE OVER THE- I THE-
AYE JUSTIFICATION THAT THEY
WOULD BE MORE RESPONSIVE TO OUR
NEEDS- THAT HAS NOT BEEN THE
CASE SO. WITH THE SIXTY FIVE U.
I. T. PROJECTS LANGUISHING-
WE'RE NOT GETTING AN ANSWER YES
WE'RE NOT GETTING AN ANSWER NO
SO IN CLOSING. WHEN YOU
CONSIDER CHRONIC MAKE YOUR
RATE. HIRING LETTER G. AND
DIVERTING STAFF TO UNRELATED
WORK- WE WOULD ASK THAT YOU
GIVE SERIOUS CONSIDERATION TO
NOT APPROVING ISSUE SEVEN THANK
YOU SHARE. THANK YOU. NEXT
DEADLINE TWENTY FOUR. GOOD
MORNING- MISTER CHAIRMAN
COMMITTEE MEMBERS- JONATHAN
CLAY ON BEHALF OF THE CITY OF
ENCINITAS- URGING YOU- TO
REJECT THE ASPECT OF THE
PROPOSAL IN ISSUE ONE FOR- NOT
TRANSFERRING HARBORS AND
WATERCRAFT FUND TO THE BEACH
SAND REPLENISHMENT PROGRAM-
JUST AS BACKGROUND THIS FIND
HELPS- FUND BEACH RESTORATION
PROJECTS TO NOT ONLY PROTECT.
PUBLIC SAFETY PUBLIC ACCESS AND
PUBLIC INFRASTRUCTURE BUT ALSO
HELPS THE STATE AND LOCALS
DRAWDOWN AGAINST FEDERAL
DOLLARS. IN ENCINITAS SOLANA
BEACH FOR EXAMPLE THE PROJECT
THERE THE STATE HAS ALREADY
INVESTED TWO POINT SEVEN EIGHT
MILLION DOLLARS FOR A PROJECT
THAT'S SUPPOSE TO BEGIN IN A
YEAR. THAT IS DRAWN DOWN FIVE
POINT TWO MILLION IN FEDERAL
FUNDS AS WELL AS- LOCAL
DOLLARS. WE REALLY THINK THAT
THIS PROGRAM NEEDS TO CONTINUE-
WE UNDERSTAND THE DYNAMICS OF
THE OVERALL FISCAL STABILITY OF
OUR PERSONAL WATERCRAFT
REVOLVING FUND BUT WE URGE YOU
TO ENSURE THAT MONEY STILL PUT
INTO THIS PROGRAM SO THAT THIS
CAN CONTINUE AND- BONTA PROTECT
PUBLIC HEALTH AND SAFETY THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. YOU'RE WELCOME
THANK YOU. NEXT DEADLINE CAN.
YEAH THANK YOU A GOOD MORNING
AND THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
BUDGET SUB COMMITTEE- MEMBERS
MY NAME IS WINSTON OFFICE AND
PRESIDENT OF RECREATIONAL
BOATERS OF CALIFORNIA I'M ALSO
VOTER AND LIVE IN REDWOOD CITY.
OUR ORGANIZATION IS NOT IN A
POSITION TO SUPPORT THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSED PLAN TO
INCREASE VOTER REGISTRATION
FEES BY 210050% STARTING JULY
FIRST- AND YOU'VE ALREADY HEARD
FROM OTHERS ABOUT THE-
REQUESTED WE'VE MADE TO D. W.
I. TO GET. INFORMATION ON WHERE
OUR MONEY IS GOING AND WHAT THE
STATUS WAS AND WE DIDN'T GET IT
UNTIL JUST BEFORE THE NIGHT
BEFORE THE- BUDGET SUB
COMMITTEE FOR THE SENATE-
SUBCOMMITTEE- THAT IS AN EIGHT
HUNDRED AND SEVEN MILLION
DOLLARS. THAT WE PAY IN FUEL
TAXES AND WE ONLY GET FIFTEEN
MILLION BACK. THIS INFORMATION
IS ALARMING AND CONFIRMS OUR
SUSPICION THAT BOATERS FUEL TAX
DOLLARS ARE BEING STEADILY AND
INCREASINGLY REDIRECTED AWAY
FROM H. W. R. F. INTO STATE
GENERAL FUND. AND FUNDS IN THE
STATE PARKS- THE TIMING OF
THIS- TO A 50% INCREASE COULD
NOT BE WORSE DURING AN
UNPRECEDENTED. UNPRECEDENTED
PANDEMIC WHEN INDIVIDUALS ARE
FINDING OUTDOOR ON THE WATER
RECREATION BE SAFE AND
ENJOYABLE ACTIVITY PROVIDING
SIGNIFICANT MENTAL AND PHYSICAL
BENEFITS IN TWENTY TWENTY.
THERE WAS A DRAMATIC INCREASE
IN THE NUMBER OF BOTH PURCHASED
AND REGISTRATION FEES SALES
TAXES PROPERTY TAXES AND NONE
OF THAT REFLECTED IN THEIR
REQUEST. WE COULD ENTERTAIN A
COLA- BASED THE JUDGMENT TO
REGISTRATION FEES SINCE TWO
THOUSAND FIVE IT'S BEEN A WHILE
AND OTHER THAN MEMBERS ARE
MENTIONED AS- POSSIBLY TURN
AROUND. SACRAMENTO GREAT. YEP
IT'LL ADD SO- ABSOLUTELY AND
FROM TWO DOLLARS EVERY TWO
YEARS TO SOMETHING AROUND
TWENTY SIX TWENTY SEVEN DOLLARS
EVERY TWO YEARS THANK YOU SO
MUCH. THANK YOU VERY MUCH. NEXT
DEADLINE FOURTEEN. GOOD MORNING
MR CHAIRMAN ASSEMBLY MEMBERS
I'M PETER PHILLIPS THE SAN
DIEGO BORDER AND MEMBER OF THE
R. BOC BOARD AND PROVIDING
COMMENTS ON THE DB W. H. OF
YOUR APP DEFICIENCY ISSUE I'D
LIKE TO EMPHASIZE AS YOU'VE
HEARD THAT BOATERS PAY MORE
THAN REGISTRATION FEES TO
CALIFORNIA STATE AND LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS WE HAVE
CONFIRMATION THAT BOATERS PAY A
HUNDRED AND SEVEN MILLION
DOLLARS EACH YEAR IN FUEL TAX
DOLLARS TO THE STATE WE ALSO
KNOW THAT BOATERS PAY
SIGNIFICANT PROPERTY TAXES TO
THE COUNTIES. IN WHICH WE
RESIDE EIGHT LAW RECOGNIZES
THESE PROPERTY TAXES HARBORS
AND NAVIGATION CODE SECTION SIX
SIX THREE POINT SEVEN PROVIDE
AN INCENTIVE FOR CALORIES
COUNTIES THAT EXPAND A 100% THE
AMOUNT RECEIVED BY THE COUNTY
FOR PERSONAL PROPERTY TAXES ON
VESSELS FOR BOATING SAFETY
PROGRAMS TO RECEIVE H. W. R. F.
MONEY WE THEREFORE URGE THE
COMMITTEE TO RECONSIDER THE
PROPOSED TWO HUNDRED AND 50%
REGISTRATION INCREASE WITHIN
THE CONTEXT OF THE SIGNIFICANT
ADDITIONAL MANDATORY TAXES
BOATERS CONTRIBUTE EVERY YEAR
EVERY YEAR. THANK YOU THANK YOU.
NEXT DEADLINE. NINETEEN GOOD
MORNING CHAIR BLOOM AND
SUBCOMMITTEE MEMBERS MY NAME IS
ANDREA LIQUOR AND THE PRESIDENT
OF THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION
OF HARBOR MASTERS IMPORT
CAPTAINS WE ARE AN ASSOCIATION
THAT HAS BEEN IN EXISTENCE FOR
SEVENTY THREE YEARS ALSO THE
HARBOR MANAGER FOR PORT SAN
LUIS HARBOR DISTRICT TO
COMMERCIAL FISHING AND
RECREATIONAL PORT ON THE
SUBTITLE. PARTICIPATION SAID A
CORRESPONDENCE TO YOU THIS MORE
AND THIS MORNING I JUST WANTED
TO HIT SOME HIGH POINTS IN
REGARDING THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSED ADJUSTMENT TO THE
HARBOR CRAP HARBORING
WATERCRAFT REVOLVING FUND YOU
PROBABLY ARE AWARE THAT A
NUMBER OF BOATING MARINE AND
FISHING STAKEHOLDER GROUPS HAVE
VOICED AND WRITTEN CONCERNS-
WRITTEN CONCERNING THEIR
OPPOSITION TO THE PROPOSED
INCREASE IN VESSEL REGISTRATION
FEES WHILE OUR ASSOCIATION OF
HARBORMASTER AND PORT CAPTAINS
IS NOT SIGNED ON TO THAT GROUP
OPPOSITION LETTER. IT'S VERY
IMPORTANT TO KNOW THAT WE ARE
ALSO CONCERNED ABOUT THE
INCREASE. AS YOU KNOW AND HAVE
HEARD THIS MORNING WE RECEIVED
A LETTER FROM D. B. W. A FEW
DAYS AGO IN. RESPONSE TO OUR
GROUP CORRESPONDENCE THAT WAS
SENT LAST MAY. AND THAT
CORRESPONDENT CONCOURSE BOND
AND TO RAISE THE NUMBER OF
QUESTIONS AND CONTAIN REQUEST
FOR DIALOGUE AND INFORMATION.
CENTER SEATING THAT DB W.
RESPONSE AND WE DO APPRECIATE
THAT OUR ASSOCIATION HAS NOT
HAD TIME TO FULLY DIGEST THE
TOTALITY AND FROM INFORMATION
PRESENTED. AND WE DO EXPECT A
LETTER RECEIVED TO ALLOW US TO
FULLY UNDERSTAND WHERE THE
DOLLARS GO AND HOW THE PROGRAMS
WORK. AND CERTAINLY IF THERE'S
A NEED TO INCREASE THE IS A
REAL REALLOCATE FUNDS. IN
CLOSING- PLEASE KNOW THAT MANY
MANY OF OUR MEMBERS OF OUR
ASSOCIATION HAVE BEEN
RECIPIENTS OF GRANTS AND LOANS
FROM CRITICAL INTEREST FOR
CRITICAL. CRITICAL
INFRASTRUCTURE. AND EQUIPMENT
FROM DB W. AND WE ARE VERY
APPRECIATIVE OF THOSE
OPPORTUNITIES. HOWEVER WE DO
WANT TO ENSURE THAT THE FUNDS
DERIVED FROM THE BOATING
COMMUNITY ARE REASONABLY
BENEFITING BOATING PROGRAMS AND
SERVICES. THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK TODAY HAVE
A GOOD REST OF YOUR MEETING.
THANK YOU. NEXT DEADLINE.
THIRTEEN THANK YOU CHAIRMAN
BLOOMING COMMITTEE MEMBERS- MY
NAME'S CLEAVE HARDAKER I'M A
SAILOR IN SAN DIEGO AND I OWN A
THIRTY FOOT SAILBOAT THAT MY
WIFE AND I HAVE SALES SINCE
NINETEEN NINETY ONE I'VE BEEN
ON THE RECREATIONAL BOARD A
RECREATIONAL BOATERS BOARD.
SINCE TWO THOUSAND AND EIGHT.
WE RECOGNIZE AND APPRECIATE
THAT THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL
RECOGNIZES MISUSE OF THE H. W.
R. F. FOR SEVERAL PROGRAMS OF
THE MANY YEARS AND PROPOSES TO
CURTAIL THEM. HOWEVER WHILE THE
PROPOSAL WITH KNOWLEDGE IS THAT
EXPENDITURES FROM FUND OF GONE
TO PROGRAMS ARE OF LITTLE OR NO
BENEFIT TO BOATERS. THE REMEDY
PROPOSED IS TO RECONSTITUTE THE
FUND BY IMPOSING A TWO HUNDRED
AND 50% SEE AN INCREASE ON
VOTERS. THE VOTERS OF THE SAME
MEMBERS OF THE COMMUNITY WHO
HAVE BEEN HARMED BY THE
MISALLOCATION OF FUNDS. THIS
PROPOSAL AMOUNTS TO ADDING
INSULT TO INJURY. THE FUNDS IN
QUESTION. PUBLIC BEACH
RESTORATION AQUATIC INVASIVE
SPECIES. QUABBIN GEBO MUSSEL
INFESTATION WHICH IS ALREADY A
SURCHARGE ON BOTH REGISTRATION
FEES. ARE ALL OF LITTLE OR NO
BENEFIT TO VOTERS. SO THESE
PARTICULAR LONG TERM PROBLEMS
AROSE ON THE EXPENDITURE SIDE
OF THE LEDGER. SO THAT IS WHEN
SOLUTIONS MUST COME FROM AND
THOSE SOLUTIONS COULD BE
PERMANENT. THE OVERALL SOLUTION
SHOULD NOT BE A 210050% FEE
INCREASE IMPOSED UPON HUNDREDS
OF THOUSANDS OF VOTERS IN THE
STATE. THE DEPARTMENT MUST
IDENTIFY AND SECURE FINANCIAL
RESOURCES FROM OTHER
BENEFICIARIES OF THESE
PROGRAMS. AND MUST SEEK TO
REDIRECT SUBSTANTIAL AMOUNTS OF
THE VOTERS FUEL TAX. TWO
HARBORS A WATERCRAFT REVOLVING
FUND. THIS IS THE APPROPRIATE
SOLUTION FOR DEVELOPING FOR
SOLVING THE IMBALANCE. IN
ADDITION CONCERN THAT WE HAVE A
SEPARATE LETTER WHICH IS THE
PROPOSED CORPORATE OFFICE. YEP
OUT COMMUNITIES REQUEST FOR
MEANINGFUL ENGAGEMENT WOULD
OCCUR AFTER THE INTERVENTION
IMPLEMENTATION OF THE TWO
HUNDRED AND 50% REGISTRATION
FEE INCREASE AND THIS IS
PUTTING THE CART BEFORE THE
HORSE THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. NEXT DEADLINE TWENTY FIVE.
MY NAME IS REALLY SHORT I AM
THE IMMEDIATE PAST CHAIRMAN OF
THE BOATING AND WATERWAYS
COMMISSION. I WAS APPOINTED BY
GOVERNOR BROWN IN TWO THOUSAND
FOURTEEN AND SERVED UNTIL LAST
YEAR. I'M ALSO REPRESENTING THE
MARINE RECREATION ASSOCIATION.
BUT FIRST I'D LIKE TO SHOW
THEIR APPRECIATE THE VERY GOOD
QUESTIONS ASSEMBLY MEMBER SMITH
ASSEMBLY MEMBER STEEP GRANITE.
THE CURRENT FINANCIAL
CHALLENGES HAVE BEEN KNOWN. FOR
MORE THAN FIVE YEARS SO THE
SOLUTIONS PROPOSED TODAY. COULD
HAVE BEEN SHOULD HAVE BEEN
ADDRESSED INVENTED WITH BOATERS
IN THE MARINE INDUSTRY PARTNERS
THE PARTNERS HAVE NOT BEEN
ENGAGED. THE VESSEL
REGISTRATION INCREASE IS
COMPLICATED AND HAS PROPOSAL
IMPACT A LITTLE DOES THE MOST
THE WEALTHIEST BOATERS WILL
CONTRIBUTE LITERALLY NOTHING HI
THIS ITEM NEEDS FURTHER
CONSIDERATION BEFORE THE SET UP
TO. THE SECOND GOVERNMENT IS
IMPORTANT ISSUE IS THAT THE
FUNDING OF THE LOAN PROGRAM
WHICH WILL CREATE FURTHER
FINANCIAL NEGATIVES FOR BOATING
AND WATERWAYS. BECAUSE BOATING
AND WATERWAYS USES THESE LOAN
REPAID BACK OF THESE LOAN FUNDS
FOR OPERATIONS AND SO THIS WILL
CREATE A- IN IMMEDIATE.
SOLUTION IN A LONG TERM PROBLEM
THANK YOU FOR YOUR ATTENTION
THANK YOU. NEXT DEADLINETWENTY.
YES IF YOU'RE TEARING COMMITTEE
MEMBERS MY NAME IS TODD LATE
HOLLISTER I AM A VOTER FROM
LONG BEACH CALIFORNIA AND I
SERVE ON THE BOARD OF THE
RECREATIONAL BOATERS OF
CALIFORNIA AS WELL I ALSO AM
GOING TO SPEAK ON ISSUE NUMBER
ONE THE FINANCIAL ABILITY. FOR
BOATING PROGRAMS. BECAUSE THE
ISSUES OUTLINED BEFORE ME- WE
RECOMMEND YOU TAKE THE
FOLLOWING ACTIONS. NUMBER ONE
REDUCE THE AMOUNT OF THE
PROPOSED INCREASED THE AMOUNT
SIGNIFICANTLY LESS THAN 210050%
NUMBER TWO REDIRECTED SMALL YET
REASONABLE PORTION OF A HUNDRED
AND SEVENTY MILLION IN ANNUAL
BOTH FUEL TAXES TO THE H. W. R.
S. NUMBER THREE. PERMANENTLY
ELIMINATE THE AUTHORITY OF H.
W. R. ABS FUNDS TO BE UTILIZED
FOR BEACH EROSION CONTROL.
NUMBER FOUR THE STAFF WAS
EQUITABLE FUNDING STRUCTURE FOR
THE INVASIVE SPECIES PROGRAM
THAT INCLUDES OTHER
BENEFICIARIES WITH THE
PROPORTIONAL FINANCIAL
FRAMEWORK. NUMBER FIVE THE
STAFF WAS INSTEAD THE
STAKEHOLDER PROCESS TO BE
UNDERTAKEN OVER THE NEXT FEW
YEARS TO DEVELOP LONG TERM
FUNDING APPROACHES FOR THE H.
W. R. AT. AND LASTLY. NUMBER
SIX ADD TO THE BURDEN WATER
RATES COMMISSION STATUTORY
AUTHORITY THE RESPONSIBILITY TO
APPROVE LOANS AND GRANTS FROM.
BIG WRS TAKEN TOGETHER THESE
ACTIONS WOULD PROVIDE
ASSURANCES TO THE STATE'S
VOTING COMMUNITY THAT THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA IS TAKING A
BALANCED. REASONABLE APPROACH
WOULD INCREASE TRANSPARENCY TO
ADDRESS THE BOATING REVENUE IN
A MATTER. THAT RESPECT TO
PROPER USE OF RESPOND FOR
BOATING PROGRAMS AND SERVICES
THANK ADDRESS. BOTH THE PUBLIC.
THANK YOU THANK YOU. THERE ARE
NO FURTHER COMMENT AT THIS TIME.
WELL THANK YOU ALL FOR YOUR
COMMENTS WHICH WERE
PREDOMINATELY ON- IF YOU WANT A
COUPLE OF QUESTIONS ON THE-
CALCIUM ISSUE- WILL CERTAINLY
TAKE ALL THOSE COMMENTS INTO
CONSIDERATION WILL BE TAKING NO
ACTION ON ANY ITEMS TODAY AND
THAT BRINGS OUR MEETING. TO
CONCLUSION WERE ADJOURNED. LARA
IF WE DON'T TECH WORLD WE.